[Music]
hello everybody happy Monday
April 10th
beautiful uh Easter Post Easter Monday
he has risen
he has risen he's up
and I'll tell you he's up what's up now
and I'll tell you what else is risen
my blood pressure I was gonna say that
you were gonna say that yeah yeah
because
um I guess some of you may know some may
not oh by the way today's episode is
sponsored by PayPal honey thank you so
much
we love our sponsors yeah you guys some
of you may have heard some not
um last week
I discovered that bbtv Broadband TV
which is an MCN which I think a lot of
people don't even know what it is
but uh
they over the course of the last two
years
have in my opinion stolen 620
000 from us
and when we discovered it I wrote them a
letter acquiring like a patient and nice
letter inquiring
uh be like hey I'm assuming this is an
honest mistake let's figure it out
and then on Friday after the show they
called us to tell us that uh they're not
paying us back and basically
what I interpreted as a giant middle
finger and telling me to get bent tough
[__] he said LOL we got you idiot but
they didn't actually the contract is
clear and their intentions are clear
uh I have and by the way as I get into
this I have a whole Saga you guys I've
got I'm gonna cover the whole thing but
I've got the phone call recorded
I've got the threatening emails letters
that their lawyer sent us twice and my
responsive course
also I do want to say straight up off
the bat as I'm I'm trying to be as safe
and and respectful
and above board as possible that's why
this all there will never be a frame
here
that says in Ethan's opinion so that
they if they can never claim they never
get a single [__] frame of me that
doesn't say in my opinion everything I'm
saying is in my opinion
okay also I do want to say at the top of
the show
because obviously this is contentious uh
between me and Broadband TV and their
CEO
that I want to say do not do not send
hate or harassment
to any employee
of bbtv
anyone Associated do not eat don't say
anything don't say nothing to nobody
this is between me and them and our
attorneys
so while I think it's important that I
tell you guys exactly what happened well
I think that truth and Justice is
uh
uh absolutely Paramount in this
situation which is why I'm doing this I
want it to remain contained here as far
as you guys are concerned and please do
not
do not harass
name call
direct don't do anything like that okay
leave them alone we're gonna get them
Legally Legally right
and you know I would want to say you
know like the the thumbnail is fun it's
a fun goofy kind of War situation but
that's just that's just a joke it's just
a it's a goofy War it's like it's one of
the goofy Wars you know well it's like a
metaphor it's an old timey War it's not
it's like a work listen there's a comedy
podcast it's a joke it's like it's a
metaphor I'm going to war with them you
know what I mean it's a joke
you know just having a big joke out of
it well yeah well it is quite serious
but
uh so that's what I just want to say
that okay
um it's fun
to an extent we're gonna have fun here
because it's it's my it's important to
me to turn what is the worst situation
possible someone's stealing 620 000 from
me and telling me to [__] off into
something that we can enjoy here as a
community
but we're gonna keep it in the community
we're going to keep it in the community
so thank you I want to put those
important disclaimers out there
okay
so with all that being said
uh well Howie Mandel's calling in at 115
actually
if I gotta talk to him first we gotta
talk to America's Uncle because Howie
did Howie you know on the good oh he he
said he might be a little late okay
he actually let's do some good news how
we
did some really nice things for us
over the weekend ela's coming to join us
because we all want to thank him but
he is such a nice guy I think he's like
the nicest dude alive
and I'll show you guys exactly what I
mean
um how did this even start so how we he
was on the show we gave him some Teddy
fresh
and then he started wearing it
um
to shoot America's Got Talent
and there's always Paparazzi outside
taking their photos so this man first of
all shows up in this stunning
full Teddy fresh outfit
and he he looks so good in it doesn't he
he's killing it he's killing it like
he's pulling it off so so majorly
and then this was from uh
was it the Daily Mail
and they even they even wrote it out
they said uh Howie Mandel 67.
why do you gotta hit him with the age
why you gotta do that they mentioned
Heidi and Sophie don't mention her name
Sophia
appeared in High Spirits as he greeted
fans and posed with Tokyo chicken
wearing a Teddy fresh oil spill design
look at that [__] called it out
but then the next day and we're like yo
Howie you're the man we love you so much
it's so nice of you we posted it
everyone loved it he came back the next
day
with another one
this is ela's send help sure and by the
way
again pulling it off like this man is
actually wearing a bowling hat and
looking fly as hell
doesn't he look amazing he looks good
and the way he's putting out his hands
too like uh well on Easter mm-hmm
he has risen yes
he's up
you know uh he even showed the back
blink twice if you need help
he's the man and we're just like oh my
we're gushing we're like Howie you're
just ah you're so awesome we love you so
much
and then uh
what happened next there was something
here I texted him let me let me
he made an offer for I don't want to get
this wrong because it's so nice what he
did
oh yeah he says
he says my stylist just bought the teddy
fresh wash denim Jacker jacket for me to
wear on AGT
I was like dude I were just gushing like
oh my god dude you're the greatest I
love you so much like oh my God and then
he goes here's that my stylist number
she does every Big Show including highly
Heidi klum's
Joe I was like are you freaking kidding
me right now
so I think what happened was Ila called
her directly
and then
and then how we showed up to AGT and
showed them Heidi Klum and Sophia uh
bergara regara bergara Vergara
some of the clothing and then the both
of them were like
um
I love this sweater
here they both they both look you could
come to Elis here
they both loved this sweater
here's Sophia wearing it where's the one
with the
Heidi is it in here I the link uh number
two in the dock that's this one I don't
know that's three on three
the first oh yeah here's Heidi she
posted
herself or then we posted yeah she
posted this or it was on the it was on
The Daily Mail so here's Heidi Klum
wearing the I will accomplish nothing
today they love this Sophia loved it and
by the way it was Howie who was in there
well you were there so
so he was like yo Ela if you come or was
the you tell what happened I don't I
don't know I'm so excited gila's here
what are we doing we're doing the
rundown of what yeah and I was I was
talking about you talk to okay how we
gave you the stylist number yes yeah so
I reached out because I was like I
wanted to get to know how a stylist she
seems cool
so I said hey what's up nice to meet you
maybe we can get on a call or something
to get to know each other
and she she was like yeah let's talk
tomorrow and then
maybe like 10 minutes later she sent me
a text so actually Heidi wants this
sweater from Teddy fresh
uh how he was showing her the the line
and she wants to wear it tomorrow
for the arrival and so I was like okay
let me check if we have it we thought
that we do have it and she said if you
want you can come by now and hand
deliver it to her
so that's it was all so quick and like
here it is I was like of course I'm
gonna do it I have to say yes so you
rolled down there on short notice it was
pretty late yeah I got there around
seven in the evening and they were just
about
done recording they still had like they
were judging just like three more
performances so I got to
see them judge and then in between they
take like a couple minute break so in
between they had me go talk to them
and Howie you were telling me was so
sweet how he was like pressing them like
you need to he was like a proud dad like
there's no other way to describe it and
he was so sweet
and he's just like Heidi check her out
look at this look at the sweater
um so you're gonna wear it you're gonna
wear it right and Heidi was like so
confused because it's like I was giving
it to her and then she's like okay what
do you what do you guys want me to do
with it they're like on stage recording
um but and then he saw that I had two
and he was like you want Sophia to wear
it Sofia Sofia do you want to wear it
and and honestly I didn't realize like
how famous Sophia Vergara is too love
she's huge yeah huge I'm literally
watching Modern Family right now that's
that's what I'm I'm about to go watch it
now because she's like everybody is
obsessed with her
so
I it was like I was just speechless the
whole time you gave it to her not
expecting anything no but then the next
day
she main posts it to her Instagram and
tags us yeah like what the heck
29 million followers
oh how he wants to go on at 135 what
Abby 29 million followers 29 million
followers
and it did really good too it got 160
000 likes
like that was so I was like oh my God
what is happening this is all how we
made all this happen and I mean thank
you to them too for being so gracious
and nice about like Howard what do we do
about it Uncle Howard
it's just crushed it you know I'm just
ugh so cool
so and by the way I talked to Howard on
the phone you're Howie I don't want to
call it Howard now all of a sudden yeah
like what's happening here I just you
know I just love him that much
um
he called me on the phone okay and he
was like uh Sophia was raving about the
quality it felt so good she said it's
like she felt so designer wow and then
she was looking on the website trying to
pick up more stuff he said they were
loving it so I was like oh my God this
is just great it's so cool
um so that's it I wanted to just have
Howie call in so that we could thank him
and just tell him how great he is but
he's caught
that
[Music]
um
they are promised to be wrapped at 1 30.
so once he's done he'll immediately hop
up okay so we can putts around till 1
35. Ela made a cool Tick Tock about it
here we can watch this
it has a little music background I don't
know if that's a problem
well it's basically what we just said
yeah
um
yeah yeah and then afterwards I got to
talk to them a little more when they
were down recording the show and by the
way it's such a hard job the judging
because like this people come on
obviously it's their biggest chance to
you know make it and it's ever it's so
emotional and then the crowd is cheering
for them
you saw people crying while you were
there yeah
and let them pass and I guess Simon
sometimes give it like a second chance
to see if the judge has changed their
mind yeah and I was sitting next to his
stylist and she was like how he's not
gonna change his mind he never does dude
how is this the straight gatekeeper he
knows what's good and what's not what
did you agree with his assessment I mean
it's so hard to separate the emotional
from the you felt bad Talent it's really
hard like this was my only opportunity
now I need to go back to abstract
poverty and live on the streets with my
two younger siblings I take care of them
by but I may I sell sandwiches on the
street we have nothing I always like get
the [__] out of here no cry more baby
awesome oh and afterwards a bunch of
people work on the show wanted to come
take pictures with me oh my good yeah
who is she
um so we
took pictures and I was like Sheriff
likes a little bit on this famous people
okay
see people know who I am
yeah so
um and it was really cool to see the
behind the scenes then they had like a
hundred monitors oh yeah you know that's
a big show that's like one of them
potentially yeah and the big camera on
the crane I always love those the jib
yeah by the way they probably do have a
crane for something of that but um did
you see this man is this covid related
how he's a famous Tick Tock Howie Mandel
posting a prolapse [__] on Tick Tock
elohan delivering
that is you know the dominoes this is
funny but the dominoes actually go
further back it should go all the way
back to Howie randomly charging you at
the park at the mall that's how it
really all started mall or whatever well
yeah he at the Malibu yeah oh my God
Country Mart or whatever
it's freezing in here dude
I just wrote Cinema no I'm cold
how many minutes ago did you send I'm
hot
like I can't look I'm doing I'm doing a
show here I'm right under the bed I
lowered it was 11 minutes I can't you
know what I mean like
wait you guys got to see the shirt I'm
wearing oh yeah show it off
let's go
it's a vintage Howie t-shirt wow
look at that I love nuts tour anybody
feeling nuts today I'm feeling Yes
actually I am feeling nuts today
um one of the family
members of our podcast is uh he has a
vintage shop and he sent me this t-shirt
oh
so awesome yeah so but after
um Howie calls in you know what's what's
coming
and uh actually I I was going through
preparing the call with bbtv which you
were on by the way and Gila had some
great moments in there I thought I even
put a note in today
oh yeah dude you actually had like one
of my one of the really important
interjections which one where you made
him clarify does the CEO
yeah because they were continually
trying to avoid I think they were trying
to protect her from accountability was
clear that this was her decision as the
CEO I mean who else's decision is it but
she ELO kept making them clarify is this
the CEO's decision you don't want to
mess
which was I thought that was so smart it
was so smart I was having flashbacks
during that call to us
when we first moved here and we had the
other call and I was crying and I was
like Look At Me Now
no way I'm gonna cry on this car I'm
gonna make you cry
you know
that's so I was like if anybody's crying
here you're gonna cry not me you seems
like he was about to at some points
um
because yeah when we first moved here we
got screwed over by MCN we got screwed
over and at that time it was like that's
everything and if we can't make money
we're screwed like everything is on the
line you can't you can't mess with our
income right now because it's like every
month is a month by month you know it
was getting by it was with the studio
studio 71. they read they rebranded
because they got so much [__] what was
that they were called creative yeah uh
you know just like like I love that they
just try to change their name and hope
everyone yeah that's what scumbags they
are
what it was is that at the time for
doing reaction videos it was super
important to be in the managed program
right because it will exclude you from
the auto claiming system right so
anything we would react to immediately
get claimed and then we wouldn't be able
to monetize anything right and we you
try to explain that to them from the
moment they started talking to us
because that's the only thing we cared
about and they said they could do it all
throughout the country yes Collective
that was the one so
all throughout the conversations and
everything and emails they said they
would do it and then the moment we
switched over to them they didn't do it
and and then everything gets claimed and
it was like a big crazy [__] show and so
we got on a call with them and we're
like well if you can do it let us go of
this network and they're like no you
sign a contract yeah I do it and I was
like are you serious I think you guys
said you could do it we signed the
contract yes but you said you could do
it and now you're not doing it and and
and that that was when I started crying
and the guy was like welcome to whatever
how did he say it Welcome to the Real
World yeah you sign a contract
yeah organizing us like who the [__] are
you and then I found out this guy was
telling people behind the scenes don't
work with them yeah they also said that
his name oh such any cat that's the guy
that kept calling you buddy oh yeah
buddy
so what's what's interesting as that was
my first lesson on these MCN things
and I thought I had learned enough and
mistrust the mcns enough and now I feel
like such a [__] idiot because I'm
probably getting scammed the hardest for
the most money this is like the best
heist that mcn's even ever pulled off
and I think what they do because again
they promised us we'd be in
the managed
and I was stupid back then I didn't know
anything they do it over a phone call
and then there's no trace of it and then
they're not accountable to anything they
said that's what happened in that case
in this case
first of all with bbtv
even in the contractor 100 wrong it's
clearly written but in this case I wish
I could find our negotiating uh
conversations it was on Skype
and I have no idea how to recover those
because if I could recover those it
would be back then
yeah yeah that's where we talked about
like
the whole thing of like 100 goes to us
it's all in there it doesn't matter it's
on the contract the contract is actually
like so clear that's you don't even need
to be a lawyer to understand it
that's what I think so I don't think you
even need to try to go back and fight
but you know when I CL when I sign with
them I I tried to create a situation
where they couldn't possibly [__] us
over I know where it's like a hundred
percent of everything from YouTube comes
to us
you know
um
that was it and they go well we can take
uh if we bring you ads we can take 70 75
I was like yeah if you bring me a
sponsor sure sure right
and so they write in these lines like
that about stuff like that
and then they
they literally find a way to exploit
that
and steal your money like I don't these
businesses don't do anything honestly
what they're good at is writing super
predatory [__] up contracts and then
exploiting and manipulating and
deceiving people and taking their money
I'm pretty sure that's how they make
their money in my opinion you see what
we have here in my opinion you see this
love it try to grab a screen try to grab
a frame for the for the attorney [__]
ass dumbass lawyer you see grab the one
of me pointing to this idiot dumbass
stupid ass um
yeah the thing is that like well so are
we just like going in talking about it
well I I I
we can I just want to wait for Howie
because I was gonna actually leave after
how he's called yeah that'll be
relatively soon so
it's just stupid on the call they were
trying to argue that the membership
falls under other
and there's like I've got it all yeah
it's like there's so many ways I could
start explaining why this is not other
they're wrong in so many different
things like it's stupid I have the phone
call which I'm gonna play for everybody
and in the phone call you can hear
how they are clearly
trying to rationalize this in a way that
was not upfront that they are
understanding that this was not the
contract that we signed and that they
have
they have
underhandedly
gone behind our backs to siphon off this
money and then they're just desperate to
be like no and the contract here it says
that we can steal your money like that's
that's the tone of their justification
and and it's just so clear and you know
their attorney is so I think they're
very scared about this phone call
because their lawyer sent me a second
threatening letter last night where
they're like you may have illegally
recorded our representative I said first
of all dummy
Canada is a one-state consent second of
all send me to jail send me to jail you
understand I'm crazier than you I don't
care like I've done my due diligence
right to make sure that like this is
kosher
to the best of my abilities but at the
end of the day I don't care I'm crazier
than you are by a lot
like when will people learn this I'm
[__] insane I don't care like if you
[__] me over if you steal money from me
if you patronize me if you do any of
this [__] like you're trying to do to me
to treat me like a [__] idiot
I'm crazy dude
clown comedian I've gone I've gone
[__] Goblin mode over way less
I don't know what y'all expected like
I'm [__] nuts
you know like they go oh the I can't
wait to read these letters they're like
it's criminal you you were you recorded
the call and you broke business and
legal boundaries I said here's a
boundary you stealing 620
000 let's talk about that boundary you
broke or like saying that your videos
are unhelpful unhelpful okay
um let me help a burglar
steal my purses all right let me hold
your hand it's like you you think I'm
trying to help you yeah it's unhelpful
the only way I'll help you is give you
my bank account to pay us back that's
essentially I wrote back a real song
[Music]
foreign
yeah yeah thank you
Jesus
yeah for sure yeah you're back on the
job you got to understand as soon as you
hit the button and release you're back
on yeah yeah I know I know okay I'm
watching it back I don't know how much I
uh no you're fine you're fine I had a
pretty good but you said it like five
seconds it's just like I don't know why
it's like okay good I'm glad yeah you're
good yeah are you confirming that it got
cut
that I might that might have been the
biggest button this far the best button
ever yeah yeah it's actually it's so
good because I don't even want the
conversation to yeah the button is still
like
because we're they see back in time
they're looking at the button right now
so I'll check so it did it got it it got
it that's so sick dude the buttons
I don't know how much got cut of what I
was saying but I was just saying that
I'm [__] crazy dude
like I'm burning this whole [__] down
foreign
with me in the building yeah that's what
yeah
well I'm crazy I've done way crazier
[__] for way less
I saw somebody in chat say they hate the
button well if you like the show you
should love them
honestly yeah
what I said what I said in my opinion
was obviously nothing but what happens
in those situations is that we've been
down that road you just you don't need
to yeah put that out there yeah it's
just not productive
yeah
funny though
I got to watch one time recently when
you guys did the button and I thought it
was pretty exciting also the screen
savers are fun we have so many great
screensavers and then I kept wondering
like was the button what I watched or
was there something worse after that
that was the button
so it's kind of like a fun game as a
listener and the decode it yeah yeah
every week I've been updating the button
screen and every week we've been seeing
new ones I'm surprised you coming on the
subreddit if you got a funny idea for uh
for a card I don't even think we've come
close to cycling through all the great
buttons I'm not even close yeah that's
the game but yeah I was just saying like
I had such a great monologue there I
think it all got cut I'm [__] nuts
okay essentially you know like
um oh yeah I was saying I was saying
I want to make this point I was saying
that in the letters they sent me from
their lawyer they're like oh you're
breaking the law
you may have broken the law recording or
I don't here send me to jail
when you [__] me over it's I'm telling
you I just I'm I don't care you stole
620 000 for me do whatever you got to do
they said we're gonna hold you
accountable please do
hold me accountable
let's [__] go dude cause I'm crazy
and I don't [__]
[__] Fearless to the point where it's
it's like it's like self-defeating and
that's fine I've accepted Myself by now
and I got a [__] whole button God
you're Joker Brandon yeah
ever since this happened I'm telling you
wow I'm I say send me to jail sue me I'm
[__] telling everybody what happened
and I'm sharing the call they go you
broke legal they're like you broke legal
and ethical and business boundaries by
making those videos
yep we have Howie on the line okay
there's a [__] boundary you broke
stealing 620 000 [__] dollars
you ready for Howie yeah bring him on
I've got plenty of time to uh
all right here we go standby
Sam
and
Howie the legendary comedian number one
yes it's Howie Mandel so fashionable
you know we were just telling everybody
Howie about uh everything that
transpired and just how gracious and
amazing and just how much we love you
and I just want everybody to know just
you know Uncle may I call you Uncle
Howie
go ahead yeah that's what it is and you
know
um so here's what here's what actually
happened these guys are uh nice enough
to send me a gift box of uh Petty fresh
I've got it it's like Christmas morning
it was like this morning and what are
you saying somebody's calling me what oh
I'm on mic I'm on a TV show
can we get that on air potentially all
right now it's asking me for the mic
right now ow
well the fact that it was on lucky I
came in and did this and didn't go to
the men's room right I'm done yeah at a
live concert before I've actually ran
off stage into the bathroom and had an
entire audience of thousands of people
listen to oh they heard the whole thing
did you dump or pick yeah
okay
I'm pissed but you wouldn't know the
difference it could have been a dump it
could have been diarrhea I would have
known the difference oh well that's
that's the beauty of you anyway uh
healing and and uh Ethan sent me a
beautiful
um gift box it was like I was gonna say
like Christmas morning but I'm a Jew so
it's like it was like the third day of
Hanukkah oh the third day
I don't know this was one of the shirts
and help which is this is like so me
yeah I'm always with help and blink it
says on the back and me and my daughter
Jacqueline who I do my podcast with
Howie Mandel does stuff and we we
started wearing this stuff and then they
they started taking pictures when I go
to uh it's Got Talent yeah that's the
only game they've taken pictures and
posted pictures of them oh really oh my
gosh yeah
I was at that when I was wearing this
with the the bowler cap they put me in
that what is that that magazine out of
Berlin a highest nobody
you're gonna be I'm big you're gonna be
on GQ next
hey I don't care I like that one that
one's younger and and right I felt
really good and nah Heidi Klum the
supermodel and my friend very good
friend said oh you made it unto that
that is a cool shirt where'd you get
that oh and I said Teddy fresh
and then and then I opened I said I I
went to your website she goes oh my God
that sweater is so cool I go I can get
you that where it is and that the rest
is the story of you sew it up and get
and hand delivered it by the actual
create oh cool yeah no I was talking to
your stylist Dana and she was like
they're here today if you want to come
and delivery you can and I was like of
course I'm going to if I can yes I will
and I was telling you there and like and
then I had to tell the story on Tick
Tock tour but it's so crazy to me
because Project Runway I basically grew
up watching that show
and so I I know like the people who won
I know the struggles I know the make it
work moments and then for Heidi to want
to wear something I made it's like it's
crazy it's just crazy yeah and then she
wore the uh I will accomplish nothing
today shirt and she was with it you know
that yeah and she was with was the guy
that won last year oh really yeah let me
let me ask you something because you're
a designer I'm not I'm not making fun
and I don't know if you showed them yeah
I know we did I'll pull it up you want
me to pull it up
I mean is it not crazy are you pulling
it up it is an outfit what it is but you
know what this is what this is what you
want like you don't want to be boring
you're not boring look at these
beautiful women wearing your thing and
then look at this guy who won
I mean how crazy is that what's weird
about this Howie
what's weird about this he's got like uh
did you see the back though the back was
really pretty he's like you know it's
wet it's wedding dress Chic Howie you've
never heard of it
is strapped to the front of him his
thing is that he only does white only
white but they put they pushed him and
they were like you know you're gonna
have to work with color and he did and
it was good I said is this good she goes
everything's biodegradable it's really
good for the plan
can I eat it well I know it's like
ridiculous and you show up with
something that somebody would wear so
thank you breath of fresh air you know
wait I want to show you what I'm wearing
today
do you recognize that's so old oh my God
where did you get that it's a real
vintage t-shirt it's vintage it says
filling nut store
feeling nuts to her oh that's my hands
you're in my pocket see what I did there
oh you're feeling your nuts oh
I don't even get that a nut store
they're so you know above the got it but
anyway how we I just wanted to hear from
you and to celebrate our beloved Uncle
Howie who you're too good to us you're
too kind and you've been really kind you
know that your your following came to
Howie Mandel does stuff and ever since I
was on your show they've been supporting
me they've been and I get every prolapse
comment
um but they've been they've been
incredibly supportive they've been
watching it and I I should show you next
time we're in person in my comment
sections because we're here from H3
we're here from H3 yeah well you know
what we're all family here now and it's
just your friend oh you guys should
watch my you should watch my podcast you
know what I have on my podcast Tom
sandal telling his side it's the first
place and the only place he showed up
wait who
um Sandoval do you know what that that
is Sandoval wait why does it sound super
familiar
gandaval he's the guy from Vanderpump
Rules
you've got all this guy oh I just
started watching it oh Cali's got that
exclusive
he's coming up
what's his uh well what he's being
accused of doing is apparently he's been
living with this girl I don't watch the
show okay but he's been living with his
girl Ariana for nine years yeah
and he had an affair with her best
friend
dirty dirty dirty boy oh it's called
Sandoval but everybody's talked about it
CNN covered it and he it's the only
place tomorrow on Howie Mandel does
come and tell his side of it did you
record it already
yeah how'd you get that scoop how do you
get that scoop Howie I mean you're I
know you're Howie Mandel bus Howie
Mandel and you know let me just reach
out you're like listen this is
I mean yeah you got you got me you've
you've stalked me into a parking lot in
Malibu and got my ass to come into your
show so I did and you were looking at me
you were worried it wasn't like a warm I
went hey
please
yeah but look how your mother your
mother said I'll just take the kids
let's move let's move the kids back I
don't know what this is right right
right yeah but look how our friendship
is blossomed I mean I just we just love
you so much so thank you man you're the
you're the man you're the man I'm
obsessed with your glasses
you got to come back well these glasses
are mine yeah see I'm a designer yeah
Medina does it see I work it's your like
dude you made it it's like a
collaboration or something
no it's a a a portion of every sale goes
to uh Seth Rogen's uh hilarity for
charity so it's for Alzheimer's my mom
has Alzheimer's oh wow good for you I
always wear glasses yeah yeah yeah I see
you took my advice by the way and
stopped showing the back of your head in
your thumbnails I did I listen I'm
learning from the best
you do it's still in your banner but the
your thumbnails are way better they're
way better way better yeah
thank you you like my thumbnail yeah
they're way better than they were
you know there is
good Howie I don't know I didn't get a
chance to ask you about this I noticed
that Jeff Dunham overtook our number one
spot now I know yeah no so I'm I'm just
I'm call I'm have suspicions about the
validity of this I know Jeff Dunham he's
very insecure I think he would possibly
bought views in order to patch me your
thoughts on that
I didn't know that you can do that if
it's not your can you even buy it on my
on my podcast of course yeah they'll
watch anything you want I didn't know
you could do that I believe in my
opinion I think I can buy views of of
his I don't think he can buy views on
mine yes you can you just pay a bunch of
Indian people to come watch a video they
don't care where it is really yeah
really yeah so it might jump back on and
beat him yeah yeah ask him for me
ask him he's a nice guy he's actually a
neighbor another neighbor okay so just
say Ethan Klein he probably knows my
name maybe not
as excuse you has accused you of
viewbotting in order to pass him and
then Howie why don't you just tell your
you have way more followers why don't
you just help your followers right now
just click they don't have to watch the
whole thing watch the episode of Ethan
on Howie Mandel does stuff and just
let's surpass um you can watch it for a
couple of minutes and it'll click and
let's surpass Jeff Dunham smooth how
he's really plugging always keep it
plugging
this way I don't have to spend money no
you not no no no not you not you but you
know if ha if if we if we depose Jeff
Dunham and we do find that he indeed did
buy viewbot I'm gonna expect you to
private that video and and return my
title as number one
how do you how do you know whether
somebody bought we're gonna just we're
gonna depose him there's gonna be a
lawsuit about this and he can't lie when
he's being deposed uh it's illegal you
just you just call somebody over to your
place to depose them there's no legal
jurisdiction well I'll figure out
I got the deposing part I'm gonna figure
out we can get the the lie detector guy
he's gonna show up and no and and by the
way Howie by the way in deposition no
puppets allowed
oh
so whose ass can he put his fist up
that's it he's he's [__] without that
spicy I was thinking of that I got in
trouble from the community of prolapsers
you know that they said I was
disrespectful to that guy
all right that's just not fair I mean
you've brought you brought more
awareness to the prolapting community
than anyone ever has before biggest
Advocate
I almost vomited on your set watching
that guy blow his ass out on command and
I respect anybody for what they do but I
was picking up cut off guard and a lot
in that community
hated on me well you know what
ultimately uh they fear what they don't
understand and how we uh
you're just you're just uh this
incredible Force for good they just they
you suck it all in you're like a spot
you're like a sponge that sucks and all
the good news don't talk about somebody
blowing their ass out and then tell me
to suck it all in well I'm trying to
make it my metaphor this is why they
don't understand you because you suck in
all the goodness if they push out all
the goodness well I know they're not bad
people they just they literally expel
their prolapse yeah yeah it's hard hard
you did just different people
all right Howie I got uh I don't want to
hold you for too long I just wanted to
say that we love you and uh yeah thank
you I love you too so much yeah you're
the best the greatest uh thank you for
all the H3 fans for all the support and
go push Ethan's numbers up
are you sick
uh no I I don't know why I just cough
sometimes you know I Spit on a lot I
caught up blood sometimes and goodbye
goodbye I don't know if I can catch a
virus
no I'm fine I don't cough out blood I
have like uh I have uh acid reflux it
makes me cough sometimes yeah
isn't that usually after eating did you
just eat I have well it's like coffee
can do it right it's work it's more than
that it's a gerd it's like a chronic uh
oh I'm starting to get in and he's not
funny well you got GERD and acid reflux
yeah yeah I got it all right prolapse
this is a mess oh yeah I've been through
a lot
and hell I hope I look as good as you do
at uh your age Howie I know
seven
I'm looking for my hairline it's in the
other room all right I'll see you later
we love you Howie be good stay good
you're the best bye bye
that's how we meant though I mean who
does it better who does it better than
him he's so nice he's so gracious yeah
such a great guy so I'm ha I'm super
happy for you I'm too grateful to Howie
I mean it's a good thing's happening
thank you in the world of ela Klein and
Teddy fresh yeah that was a big moment
so actually you know what perfect timing
to thank our sponsor and then we can
jump in to the meat and potatoes of it
am I gonna leave you are you gonna be I
got the button yeah we'll keep it uh
Goblin Goblin mode is a little bit uh
this yeah this is it's like quite
extreme of a gamble I never got here I
got the button and like I'm trying to I
know what to say I'm ready I'm the
[__] Green Goblin you know it's over
they [__] up like I don't even care
about the money I'll spend more money
than they owe me to [__]
Jesus bankrupt them if possible I mean I
think I think the 620 is going to
bankrupt them in my opinion in my
opinion my opinion
hold on one second
there it is but that's it I don't even
care about the money anymore they're not
giving it back I will spend a million
dollars to legally [__] them in the ass
and I'm sorry to break that too Ila but
I know you got my back on this oh man it
works yeah no I can't [__] take this
[__] you're someone's gonna come [__]
with me again like I'm minding my own
[__] business
and now like these people are gonna come
[__] me even harder than ride Kavanaugh
did debatably 620
000 and then you're gonna get a call
with me and [__] spit my face and
expect me not to go Goblin mode that's
what I do right
I'll burn the money like Joker it's not
even about the money anymore
[__]
true Joker brand you know what I mean oh
boy
there's a lot to go over
but first let's think our wonderful
response
I'm gonna go work all right thank you
though we love you congratulations on
all your success we're all very much so
proud of you everybody and all the
comments are so nice and supportive and
it's really thank you to everybody it's
just it's a lot it has really happy
I gotta say teddy fresh is getting
better and better like I mean this
Godzilla drop was so yeah dude and the
ones to come is just like oh so many
hits yeah so you're doing awesome just
super happy about it thank you
congratulations go
head down work yeah all right
let's thank uh honey I love these guys
man honey is one of the most
loyal sponsors we've had in the
beginning of time I just I'm so grateful
to them
you loyal and a great sponsor too like
one of the best
um today's episode is sponsored by honey
of course and what they do is the easy
way to save When shopping on your iPhone
or computer
when you're browsing the internet
and you find it a deal a product you
want to buy
maybe it's on a grocery store clothing
store video games Electronics
when you go to checkout you know that
coupon code
um
field it always taunts you they're like
do you have a coupon and you you think
to yourself I know there's a coupon out
there it's gonna be a fat discount
if only I knew what it was
that's where Honey comes in they know
what it is they have the best coupon
codes available for all tons of
practically every uh retailer on the
internet that does do that
and when you click checkout it's going
to automatically sort through
find the best one it's gonna save you
the most money and automatically apply
it what you're seeing on the screen
these are all savings that we here in
this office have personally experience
this is all real [__]
dude I've literally saved thousands of
dollars without even doing anything
without even thinking about it
it's free to use you don't even have to
think about it dude you can install it
in like two quick clicks it's just a
browser plug-in
you know
just wait a few seconds
and bada bing bada boom
hey
it's it's honestly like I don't I don't
surf the internet without honey anymore
it's crazy if you're buying stuff it's
crazy and the best part now it works on
your iPhone too
you just activate it on Safari on your
phone then you can save on the go let's
freaking go
oh I'll miss you I truly truly love
honey if you don't already have honey
you could be straight up missing out on
free money and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid and supporting
this show thank you so much get PayPal
honey for free at joinhoney.com h3tv
that's joinhoney.com
h3tv thank you so much to honey we love
you all right
yeah and you know to go back to the um
the thumbnail
because I don't want people to think
that this is a war that's happening if
anything we're holding the line
it's them that came to our Shores and
stole 620 000 from our coffers
from our Treasury
this and this is an invasion we are
holding the line
not just for ourselves but for creators
everywhere
for the for everyone exploited
everywhere I fight man the barricades
this is a defensive battle
that's all dude I've never
I'm always reactionary I have never
caused this huge reactionary
hmm well not in that way but I'm saying
when it comes to like all this [__]
it's so I don't these people are doing
it to me and now actually for the first
time I am going to be a plaintiff
which is going to be interesting it's
exciting
it is experiences I mean it is kind of
it will be nice to experience it from
the other end new role
yeah I'm gonna sue the [__] out of them
it's like not even a question like do
they think I think they thought because
they're used to creators
I think a lot of creators and this isn't
a I think it's a lot of people in
general lawsuits are scary as [__] you
know
and uh it was scary as [__] to me the
first time we went through it too
yeah I mean you should be thankful that
you are I mean wealthy enough to
actually pursue this because that's the
sad reality is that most times when
people get screwed over
um you know the only recourse they have
is to Sue or something and nettle yeah
and that's such a tall order when uh you
don't have a lot of money so you know
thankfully you're in a position where
you can actually fight back again
absolutely yeah well said and so um
most I think most people would just say
like [__] it you know I don't want to
deal with this they're getting letters
from the attorneys if you try to talk
about it publicly exercise your first
amendment Free Speech they're going to
try to scare and pressure you to shut up
right which is what they've done to me
they've sent me letters saying you're
breaking dude she goes you're breaking
Community guidelines like she's going to
try to get me like suspended on YouTube
you're breaking the law I was like okay
go ahead
YouTube Community guidelines that's what
she said in the letter we'll read it
she's like you violated YouTube
Community guidelines I was like okay
dummy
you violated human decency
like I don't so I think this kind of
tactic usually works for them I would
even say always works for them
and so they really genuinely thought
that they would be able to skim this and
then when and if it was discovered that
they would be able to Strongarm
the situation where it's like hey we got
you
sorry better luck next time dummy
Welcome to the Real World whatever and
so um
but that's what I this is not
I why do people think they can do this
to me like I don't want this I don't
want a war on two fronts
well with this particular circumstance
it went unnoticed for years and you know
we even we've seen other
uh people that are partnered with them
come out and be like wait does that mean
they've been taking it from me too oh
yep they have so exactly I think they've
been doing this to a lot of people
actually getting away with it a lot of
people have reached out to me
with the info about some of the Shady
dealings they've done actually funny
enough love something happened to love
tell that story love it's so funny about
how right yeah yes I did YouTube when I
was like 14 15 16 did like video game
stuff
um and I recall this when when this came
up I was like oh this this is kind of
like a story that I had to deal with
when I was younger and I got approached
by this network
and I was like I'm gonna search bbtv in
my Gmail history turns out BP TV they
were the ones that tried to like make me
join their their thing when I was 14 and
they called TV bro they wrote called me
on Skype they emailed me they messaged
me without my parents knowledge kind of
crazy that is crazy all trying to get
you under contract where they could
basically just give money from you
without you I mean it's just yeah it's
like the whole business model is to just
kind of trick naive they knew that I
couldn't sign it they knew I couldn't
sign it so they eventually had me
email Shane with my dad and my dad just
shot that [__] down immediately because
he read about it and like this doesn't
make any sense and when he said no to
them they like tried to keep kept like
try to argue with him it's crazy well
and then when you read the contract
which I did it's all it's all just
straight up lies they can't do anything
for you and they're trying to pitch a 14
year old boy a 60 40 cut he's 14. and
also back then they could get you into
year-long contracts and then you could
not leave they would not let you leave
right and what's [__] up like even I
was trying to leave my network I'm on
the month of month and they had to um
they I can't leave they have to
authorize it like even now
they need to authorize it right and
otherwise every dollar I make is still
going to them and I just pray that
they're gonna have to they're gonna pay
me so that's actually a good point and
I've seen people asking this in the chat
and maybe you should clarify
um is it uh should we be advising people
not to like super chat or become members
no right now no so right so the
membership I had to create a new AdSense
I got that done uh relatively quickly
thankfully
so right now it's on my new AdSense
um the membership is back on and all
that membership is going to be coming to
us okay so they're supposed to
disconnect us today okay so if you guys
are super chatting and becoming members
and all that [__] don't worry it's going
to come to us
there you go okay thank you guys shut up
yeah yeah it's going to come to us
so I thank you guys for your I I'm gonna
pee before I get into the whole thing
because I'm telling you this whole
document's crazy I'm gonna pee I'm gonna
come right back and then we'll uh we'll
get started it's 14 page meticulously
argued document
Zach I don't mean to intrude on your ad
time but if I may please by all means I
just want to say that this Saturday is
the creator clash and if you haven't
gotten tickets yet raiderclash.com get
your tickets like freaking go
appreciate you and uh I guess we should
reiterate uh the plan
for us is to do another reaction stream
like we did last year uh people remember
um it'll be four members
right yeah those memories making sure
I'm not speaking online there uh yeah
it'll be a member stream on Saturday
it'll be a co-stream I guess along with
Creator Clash we won't be showing the
fight if you want to watch the fight you
have to get a digital ticket to that on
your own but if you would like to uh
have a watch along with the H3 crew and
cheer on our boy here uh tune in um what
time um is the creator Clash on Saturday
yeah it's at uh sometime okay
can't wait tune in why don't we look
that up real quick just so we can know
it's at three it's at three but is that
before the time or West Coast time West
Coast Florida starts at six
it starts at 6 p.m East Coast time 3 P.M
our time okay got it and yeah we'll
probably start streaming
uh an hour before that
um they just mess around
until it gets going so yeah if you want
to uh
if you want to do that uh come and join
us is there going to be snacks there
will be snacks I'll be there we'll have
some uh we'll have some Brews and some
snackies and all kinds of fun stuff hell
yeah should be good we drank beer Amy's
gonna [__] win and a b is gonna win
so far
uh somebody just asked what time is
career class
I already addressed that one
[Music]
Saturday is my 30th birthday and all I
want is ab's w
ow oh yeah happy birthday there's a
couple things you're gonna make your
wish come true my friend I don't know
why I say we I have no bearing on how
the fight goes but ab's gonna make your
wish trip so about that first of all one
quick thing at the top of the show
haters back the [__] off because at Law
at the battle
the endless pit of despair of losing sub
we have gained 74 subscribers this month
let's go we knew it was coming we knew
it was coming and that means that at
this rate we'll be back at 3 million in
uh 2075 years
is that right I mean 75 if we say it's
75 a month and we need what uh like 25
000. no more than that it's more than
that isn't it oh maybe it's more than
that and it's way more than that we need
one win 130 000 130 000 divided by seven
seventy five
thirty thousand divided by
75. here we go crunch the numbers baby
you have to go let's do it if this is
your first time tuning in or you're a
regular viewer but you're just not
subscribed feel free to hit that
subscribe button so we can get maybe 75
next month that'd be awesome 75 we can
get one more wow I love the ambition
thank you baby steps is progress so it's
about 144 years 144 years yeah
I'm excited I'm shooting for 143 years I
think oh ambitious no but uh
in all seriousness this is kind of
actually pretty epic for us to be in the
green because we would usually losing
like 10 000 a month ever since Frenemies
ended
and uh it's just really nice to see
actually that
some people from somewhere comment and
liking what they're seeing some new new
blood you know what I mean so thank you
guys for that also I want to give it up
to
you guys we're touching on it but a b is
has prepared his heart out he is going
to
fight dad this Saturday that's right
I'm so excited for you Abe I am pumped
I'm I cannot wait you're gonna beat his
sorry old ass
well thank you yeah I'm excited it's
crazy to think that this is over in six
days or five days rather Maybe
so you're flying out uh Wednesday is
that right yeah Okay cool so this was
this is your last time on the show isn't
it no I'll be I'll be here Wednesday I
may have to leave a little early but
I'll be here oh you're flying on
Wednesday night okay
yes so um the last one we had this
wonderful members only viewing party
where we live reacted to the show
and uh we were drinking and eating and
having a lot of fun and watching it live
so we're gonna do that again we're all
gonna be here supporting AB having a
wonderful live uh event with everybody
getting smashed and just having a great
time so thank you to all the members who
are going to join us on that really fun
day was so much fun last time I'm
drawing and this time it's going to be
even funner because av's gonna put his
ass on the [__] floor where it belong
we'll see
I'm super excited man
are you nervous you excited that's a mix
of things I'm excited to get it over
with a little bit nervous but uh yeah
more excited I'd say this time let's go
you feel like the experience last year
has made you a lot more comfortable
going into it yeah definitely yeah and
also I'm excited to see the robe uh and
the shorts that Eli's putting together
oh yeah ready new digs huh yep another
custom uh
piece for Teddy fresh for our prized
fighter a b
you know if you think about it dad's
fight was over so fast you have so much
more experience than him in the ring in
that setting
yeah right his was over like this right
and you went like the whole way all the
ones yeah you have like a hundred times
as much professional boxing yeah yeah
I can't I'm so excited for you baby and
I'm proud of you man thank you you're
working your ass off you've been working
at the show you've been training super
hard you know this man does it all he
makes the BTS we should all give it up
for the incredible
hard-working reliable
ass beating a b burrito making thank you
thank you and thank you for the
opportunity it was that was definitely
the coolest thing I've ever been a part
of and of course I would have never
gotten it without you guys so thank you
so much appreciate it well it's cool man
you made it your own man and you put all
in the work that everyone everyone got
excited to watch you because everyone's
like damn this guy's putting in the work
you know so it's gonna be it's gonna be
that again I can't wait
people asking about your walkout song
have you decided they don't have public
it's nothing it's nothing special but
yeah okay it's special to you
it's special in hyping me up I feel like
yeah there you go that's all you need is
it the h33 theme song no no
wow loyal loyalties in question
just kidding all right let's move it on
so anyway we're all very very excited
thank you to all the people becoming
members right now we're gonna have so
much fun on Saturday we really are
so also yeah the Zach video it's done
it's amazing I watched the whole thing
the Zach lore video it's two hours long
and it's so much fun I was gonna post it
on Sunday but I feel like the whole
thing got overshadowed by this by this
whole drama controversy thing so I
didn't want I want that to have the
spotlight on its own we'll probably post
it this coming weekend
but you got career class this weekend Oh
[__] so then probably in two weekends
because it's just it's all nice it's a
masterpiece I want it it is great I
don't want to watch it back this weekend
as well it's a lot of fun I'm very
honored
so good dude so many great Zach moments
man
all right so let's do this so
broadbandtv okay
so I'm gonna start from the top I mean
ultimately and MCN is a multi-channel
network that's what bbtv is
going back you know five years ago plus
mcns were super important it was one of
my main criticisms of YouTube is that
they gave these mcns which were
predatory
and pointless way too much power for
example there was monetization tools
that were only accessible
through mcn's
um
right at one point that was correct me
if I'm wrong the way to get paid from
making YouTube videos like you had to
have one to get monetized is that right
that might be right [__] I forget the
really early because at the time getting
monetized by yourself was like yeah you
couldn't do it you're right right back
in the day I think you're right I
totally forgot that you couldn't even
get paid unless you were part of an MCN
and they forced you into these
incredible toxic predatory relationships
where like love said and a lot of we
were kids we know anything about doing
legal [__] we're just YouTubers you know
what I mean and so they would they would
do like these crazy splits like 60 40
for years at a at an end and then they
would they wouldn't let you out
and so
and so we were forcing these really
horrible relationships but uh
as YouTube progressed and there was more
MCN scandals for example there was one
that happened somewhat recently with
defy media
they just stopped paying creators
they just oh oh
yo look at this the quartering just put
out a video uh defending me let's go
Jeremy poor
demonetized I don't know what that means
oh because our I guess we were that did
happen it did happen yeah yeah it did I
just don't think that that's the main
thrust
uh-oh but you do what you do Jeremy I
love that you're supporting me thank you
King so there's a dub for Jeremy but we
love Germans the quartering I've always
seen the show I've always said it you
know I have a weird song listen I do
I know what you mean because he has like
kawaii simping for us in a way yeah I
think
you know what's funny even uh Charlie
critical uh defended me although I will
say the top comment was pretty funny it
said you don't have to like Ethan to see
this as bad
at this rate his wife's boyfriend
will have to buy him another switch
okay who's my wife's boyfriend I don't
know
they're just you're a brother
when did Jeremy get this kind of
audience I don't or Jeremy I know Jeremy
does when did Charlie get this kind of
audience but there you go you don't even
have to like me
bro they can't I love that you can't you
can't even defend me you know it seems
like yeah he's a piece of [__] but he's
not wrong in this case
thank you
oh we got a time stamp from Jeremy this
is funny how he starts it off yeah
[Music]
oh now I must have all right oh
and Klein it is one of the most
difficult things yeah you have to do but
well I understand Jeremy he says it with
a lot of love he's laughing he loves me
he loves you
poor yeah okay so anyway I was I was so
we were all kind of forced into these
predatory relationships with mcns like
why
and they were [__] everybody over and
their services became at first they were
like a management company and they could
guarantee certain like Revenue splits
and stuff and it made sense to go with
them but quickly quickly after
it turned into them just making all
these false promises like that you'll
get better rates with us that we can
help you go viral and all this [__]
that's obviously false
thank you for advertising yeah and you
had to be a part of this so what
happened in my case is
we made our AdSense account in Israel
and when we moved to America you can't
change your AdSense address
you have to cancel the AdSense and make
a new one
and to do that would drop my channel out
of monetization and it can take like two
weeks to get the new AdSense account
approved so
for me to the only way for me to
actually get paid was to be a member of
a network because they send the money to
bbtv and then to me
and so I knew
that leaving Broadband TV
would be this really horrible mess for
me where everything would be demonetized
all the memberships would be paused and
I potentially have to wait like two
weeks with no monetization now luckily
it got
I did it this week and I finally had to
do it it got approved really fast so I'm
thankful I think someone on YouTube
probably was on top of it
uh to expedite that so it was only down
for like a day
or half a day so now we're on our own
AdSense thing and I can finally monetize
but before I didn't want to deal with
this potential potentiality of being
demonetized across the board on all of
our channels for two weeks so I stayed
with them as a matter of convenience you
know and when we made this agreement
with them it was clear crystal clear it
was 100 monetization
from YouTube to me
and 75 percent of whatever if they bring
me an ad like I don't know if they bring
me they're like promote this video game
in your
in your show like a sponsorship you know
like we do on the part then they get a
cut which makes sense yeah if you guys
bring me [__] sure you can have a cut of
that makes sense which they really I
mean in the five and a half years that I
worked for you it's a handful of times
they've gotten us maybe two
they're always weird ones too
yeah
over the course of the years it may have
been more it may have been like five
something like that it was never the
expectation anyway no it was like I
don't care it was a rare exception when
we got an email from them and like let's
be real they were doing that to make
money I mean my actual agency that
brings us the ads regularly who I love
and Trust takes less cut than that right
I just don't care about what bbtv is
doing they know I know that I'm only
there for convenience so I can get paid
and they have no tangible value to a
channel like mine or any channel in my
opinion
and so
what happened well here's uh have I
described kind of how I got in this
situation and what MCN is for people
that don't know
um
and so over the years
we've stayed with them and in 2018
the membership product was launched by
YouTube now we signed our contract in
2017.
so of course it wouldn't have been
carved out it didn't exist at the time
right and because we agreed in 2017 that
all YouTube Google Revenue 100 would be
mine then I would assume of course that
would be mine too
you would also assume that if they were
going to be taking 30 percent of this
new massive Revenue stream because we've
been been our fans have been extremely
gracious to support us on the membership
and we've built you know made an effort
to build a robust Community there
that they would at least say something
that it would be a conversation that it
would be an authorization that it would
be a notification
what they did
is silently skim thirty percent
going back as far as we can record
and you know it started off as a small
amount and it's grown and grown and
grown now the reason that this was even
possible is because we had
an accountant
who was supposed to cross-check all the
money and the invoice they sent us every
month with the payment we received
I used to do that before we had a head
of Finance
and uh it's a tedious task you know as a
business owner as someone who's trying
to build my business and do lots of
other stuff
you gotta Outsource that stuff so I
trusted her to be doing that we fired
her three months ago
and we found out she hadn't been doing
that which is why this has been going on
for so long and we just noticed it
um
that's kind of what happened is I knew
she was gone so I was like well somebody
needs to make sure these payments right
well our new person gets acclimated so I
went in there and I was like yo these
are like significantly off
and that's how long did it take you to
realize that was it like you looked at
it and like immediately or like wait
none of this makes sense yeah so I
looked at our YouTube revenue and then I
looked at the pay stub and I thought
there's it must be an honest mistake
like I'm like
because it was way off like I'm talking
like where I'm just asking because it it
sounds like like you said the accountant
That was supposed to be looking at this
didn't even like occasionally look no
she didn't look at all like just she
looked never ever looked at it that's
crazy now she [__] up that was
insanely negative negligible and I'm not
going to get into it because you [__]
this she [__] us up
in ways that I don't even want to talk
about we lost a lot of money because our
but anyway
this is but okay so whatever
so yeah when I when I noticed that it
was way off first I
I wrote to my representative over at
bbtv and I was like can you tell me
what's going on here meanwhile I went to
our new Finance person and start I said
hey I'm noting this discrepancy can you
look back and tell me is this something
that's been happening every month or is
this consistent
she ran a report sent it to me
and realized you know and told showed me
the amount that they've been taking
every month uh and it had been going on
continually
since we have records to show and the
total for that was you know six hundred
nineteen thousand dollars that they had
taken from us and probably they had
taken more because the records that they
provided
before that were not thorough enough to
even know they didn't even uh categorize
the money they were taking in that way
and what's especially [__] up is that
when I started with them in 2018 I
checked every month and it was on every
month
it had always been on nobody had ever
skimmed like this and so I had no
I had no reason not to trust them
that they would be doing this you know
what I mean right so there was a there's
a it's my fault for trusting them I
guess that's their point that's one of
their main points actually in the call
which is kind of funny
it was this unfortunate situation where
we had this really horrible Finance
person who screwed us over but
ultimately as much as it is my
responsibility I can't I'm not going to
take responsibility for someone stealing
from me like you expect your business
partners not to be [__] thiefs
yeah like seems reasonable you know at
the end of the day it's like if you've
got a big ass of you know
Vault with money and you're inviting
your friends and family over
if somebody goes and opens the Vault
because it's not locked and skims some
money sure you should have locked it but
like ultimately it's their fault that
you trusted them that they came into
your house and stole your [__]
you know what I mean it's not your fault
thank you for saying that I appreciate
that
it's not your fault and so um
so once I realized that this was a
systemic thing going back two years and
it was this significant amount of money
I started to panic a little bit and I
wrote them this fat email
that was very polite
very direct I assumed that it was a I
gave them the the benefit of the doubt
to assume it was an honest mistake
and then they ghosted me for three days
and that's when I was like
this is not gonna [__] here we go
this isn't it let me open my doc let me
because here I've got I'm just going
into it if you guys are confused or have
any questions let me know because I want
to be crystal clear about
about everything I can be I worked
late Into the Night by the way to
prepare all this dude I was
14 paid meticulously argued document so
here's the letter I wrote them okay
my guy was like kind of pathetically
trying to justify it I was like this is
just some dude I need to go to the top
so I found out everyone's email I found
out the CEO's email the officer's email
whatever I put it all in there because I
was like this is serious and I want to
make sure that we're on the same page
before this escalates
so here's the email that I wrote them
on uh
I think it was Tuesday evening of last
week
dear bbtv officers
you can play the music Zach
I hope this email finds you well I am
writing today to address a pressing
matter that has come to my attention
which requires immediate action on your
end upon reviewing our financial records
I have discovered a significa a
significant discrepancy in sponsorship
Revenue that has been remitted to these
three podcast it appears that Broadband
TV has been withholding 30 of the
sponsorship money going back as far as
December 2020 possibly even earlier the
amount withheld from us as far as our
records allow us to track is six hundred
nineteen thousand one hundred one
dollars and six cents
as you are well aware our agreement with
Broadband TV which was established in
2017 clearly states that 100 of all
revenue would go to the H3 podcast the
only exception to this would be if
Broadband TV directly bought us a third
party sponsorship in which case your
company would receive a cut of that
specific Revenue it's become apparent
that this is that this understanding has
not been respected and I'm deeply
concerned about the implications of this
breach in our agreement
I am currently assuming that this
discrepancy is the result of an honest
mistake and that we will not need to
escalate the situation any further
however I must stress the urgency and
gravity of this matter it is Paramount
importance that we resolve the issue
quickly and amicably
so I kindly request a detailed plan of
action from you on how Broadband TV
attends to rectify the situation
including the reimbursement of the
entire amount withheld from us
and any other discrepancies that may be
discovered I expect to receive this plan
of action by end of the work week Friday
so I gave him till Friday
to respond I felt that I was being
gracious
I was giving them the benefit of the
doubt and I was giving them a whole week
to make a informed well-reasoned
response
failure do so will leave me no choice
but to consider alternative courses of
action
I clearly state that I wanted to you
know end this amicably
I didn't want to turn this into anything
bigger than it needed to be I didn't
want to get into another lawsuit to
another battle
I appreciate your prompt matter to this
tension of faith that we can reach an
agreeable Solution please do not
hesitate to reach out to me directly
should you have any other
uh additional information I attached our
contract as well as
uh the financial report we put together
the amount of money they were taking
from us every month
so I sent them this letter which I think
was you know Stern but but polite and
gracious
and I started to stress like I said
because three days had passed and it was
like crickets
not even my representative who's usually
pretty quick to get back to me responded
so I'm like okay these guys are talking
to lawyers these guys are having there's
like a scene probably going on back
there they're trying to figure out what
to do
but I still held hope in my heart that
they would be like this is just a
misunderstanding I didn't imagine at the
time that this was some systemic
play on their end because they've been
doing this to other people we found out
now
I didn't understand the magnitude of the
situation I hoped that it wouldn't be
like that
so I wrote my representative a few days
later before they when I hadn't heard
from them
because I was getting nervous I was like
is this really going to go down like
this like
so I just wrote him I was like so what's
going on I haven't heard from anyone is
their intent really to ignore me
I'm still a member in your network
like you're still taking my money you
could give me a response
he said leadership is working on sending
something out to you directly now when
they say leadership who do you think
who do you imagine leadership includes
I mean I don't know the scale of this
company how many people work there but
for that amount of money you have to
imagine that probably got flagged all
the way to the top pretty far there
ain't no way the CEO wasn't privy to all
this [__] yeah
and this girl this woman really you know
she accomplished something really
amazing in building this network
but at the end of the day
she I think she knows what she's doing
with this business and she's really
she's going on all these PR tours very
much a public figure about the she's
like meeting with Justin Trudeau she's
in all these magazines about being like
top Tech
uh people in Canada she's in an article
titled why ethical business transactions
is good for business I'm like
you're just stealing from me like you
know tone it down
it's just all a facade so anyway he
wrote me this he said apologies for not
following up here wanted to let the
internal discussion happen before giving
you any potential updates would amount
to more info on the way soon so that
actually made me feel hopeful
he's like okay leadership's working on
it and he says we're just triple
checking everything which I thought
meant they were like maybe checking the
amounts but actually what it meant is
they were pouring over the contract
trying to calculate how they could
justify stealing my money
that's 100 what it meant as you'll see
in the phone call
I responded thanks for the update really
appreciate it the radio silence was
making me nervous
okay then he responded are you free to
call with our SVP to go over directly
and then we arranged for a time to call
Friday after our show
which really sucked because the show on
Friday was so fun with Terry Joe
The Vibes were good everyone was stoked
SVP I think it means uh it's the senior
vice president of like partner
management or something
I gotta assume that this guy's getting a
commission all this [__] because like he
just like he this guy's like laying down
taking all the arrows for them like such
cowards to send him out
as you guys will see
I I I removed everyone's name bleeped
everyone's name involved except
for uh charzad simply because she's the
CEO she's a public
she's a public person
and I don't think it's crazy it's easy
for people to hide behind like bbtv this
oh this organization this uh monolith
like you go oh yeah BBT [__] me over
what does that mean
well charzad
rafati she is the CEO the founder of the
company the chair
so if she if she's not the one
accountable for this then who is
you know at the end of the day she's
driving this Trudeau he's going all the
way up
to the queen to the king all right
yeah so like this ship has a captain and
she's the captain
because like so somebody's got to be
accountable for this and Sh and it's her
she's a public figure she's a CEO and
founder
she's the one benefiting from this deal
and she's the one that is in my opinion
making this decision it's her call she's
the she's the king there Queen there she
wants me to take their money
non-binary uh Royal person uh non
non-binary Royal person of unspecified
gender
she is the uh entity in charge
so here is when I will
play the call for you guys
this is all in chronological order so
after Friday
I'm in the car Ila's at home
we really wanted to have this call
together
and I'm so happy that uh that it was
recorded I was in the call and I was
unable to but obviously Ela and her
[__] infinite wisdom and I'm just so
thankful to her she was so amazing on
this call and for recording it I'm just
so grateful to her for having the
presence of mine to do that
so I was feeling pretty good on Friday I
said hey maybe they're going to pay me
back you know
they're crossing their teeth on their
eyes great that sounds good nope so
here's the call we had now it's cut down
a little bit it was pretty long it was
like 30 minutes I cut down there were
some parts where
I was saying names a lot and I had to
cut it out just for clarity there was
Parts where the conversation just kind
of went off track and stuff so this is a
little bit condensed but not a lot
condensed still 16 minutes long before
you play this I just want to let you
know that a few minutes ago
Philip DeFranco dropped you are in the
thumbnail and I'm hearing reports that
he has sided with you and said thank you
[__] insane yes here is dead
yes
I was making a joke that uh Billy's back
in my good girl what I've always loved
face the prospect of a hike is there I'm
ready for that hike Philly yeah I'm
burying the hatchet but you know I was
joking like I can't wait for Philly to
drop a video about how uh
what do you guys think in the comments
well he probably did still say that well
where his take was like you know oh well
it seems a little shady but it is the
contract so I don't know what do you
guys think like not really taking a
stance no you pulled out a dub no well
give me that let me give him credit
where is it huh I'll watch the time
stamp let's do the call though let's do
the call let's say Focus we'll watch it
later yeah
so here is the call
that they threaten me with a letter
legal letter which comes later they were
very scared of this cult coming out
because I think it really really exposes
them
all right keemstar don't tell me what to
do
yeah so hey hey it's nice to meet you hi
Gila how are you good hello
good hey hey
thanks for jumping on this fall with us
um it's really important that we
um you know establish Clarity you can
hear he's scared I knew at this moment
we were it was this is not good they
were going to keep the money yeah he's
like hi Ethan have a good night it
sounded just like that I'm so glad you
picked up on that Zach I was like all
right here we go this motherfucker's
about to spit my face with respect to
the concern that you reigned
and you know you guys are being a great
partner of
team
and you know we really want to do
everything in our power to uh
um
keep you guys on board you gotta [__]
love this guy
listen uh so we really want to find a
way to keep you guys on board when he
said that I was like okay maybe they're
gonna pay us
he's like and we're doing nothing for
you so are you staying or what no I kind
of explain our thought process as to how
um we we are looking at your inquiry
into the channel membership inquiry he
calls it
that's a that's an interesting way to
put uh what I consider to be theft
yeah um
uh
hey uh birdie Bernie Madoff I have a
slight inquiry about the where you put
my money if you can just get back to me
at your earliest convenience
use from your channel is is that is that
okay to start off with
I just want to know if you're paying us
back or not yeah I wasn't I'm not I'm
not doing this corporate [__] I'm
not [__] here to listen to you waste
a second of my time just tell me are you
paying us back
are not paying
um to uh Ethan and I just want to
explain
he's scared as [__] you know he knows
what he's doing is [__] up
like you could hear it in his voice I'm
sure yeah he's this he's the sacrificial
Soldier they they sent out to absolutely
my theory is that she and other officers
were in the office with him listening
this is a very important call for them
yeah they're scared yeah so I think
everybody's kind of listening in and at
certain points there's like silence
which I think they're probably gesturing
to him that's my theory of course just
my opinion as it's clearly states here
and Ethan's opinion
right that's kind of that was kind of
the vibe that was exactly the vibe in
that room
[__] that's so funny
here here is bbtv uh on the call
as I'm talking to that guy
yeah
[__] this is gonna be a long show you
guys there's 15 minutes it's gonna take
me a long time oh boy but I'm enjoying
it and that's what matters you got to
turn lemon to Lemonade right uh bbtv
I'm over the money
I'm just [__] here for the ride
so you're not paying us back to 620 000
that you guys skimmed off of money given
to us by fans that predated our contract
which was by the way Crystal clearly uh
negotiated at the time that you guys
would give 100 of all that Revenue to me
of course I was a huge Channel at the
time I had no [__] reason to join BBT
at all can I just explain our
our overview of what we've taught the
thing is I just want to say we're both
parents we have two children here we
don't have time to spend on like the
explaining and they're trying to butter
us up and trying to this and that we've
been through this [__] so many times you
know what I mean like we know how this
goes I don't care just [__] tell me
cut the [__] it doesn't matter this
is a lot of money I'm not a 14 year old
kid that you get to intimidate
me and it's very clear and clean cut you
guys shouldn't have taken that money and
now we figured out that you did take it
and now the question is what are you
gonna do about it and that's it we just
want to go we want to cut to the chase
because I have two boys here waiting for
me yeah yes yes go ahead go ahead and
explain to me how you guys were
justified in stealing 630
000 from the starter so now that we've
established or taking the money I wanted
to have him
give his rationale to me
so I could I want to see you okay so
tell me what's the rationale and I got
it I'm happy to say he laid it all out
who wants to lose some money today
okay
I
won't and I don't agree to the premise
of stealing but let me let me explain to
our thought process so it on your on
your CPA that you signed on on page two
it defines Google net revenue do you see
it on on your agreement so so I'm put I
pull up on the screen all the [__] he
mentioned so all the relevant parts so
Google net revenue in my opinion is
self-apparent
right like Google net revenue bbtv will
pay you an amount equal to 100 of Google
net revenue
what is Google net revenue all money
paid to us from Google
all that money comes in the same basket
the memberships the revenue the YouTube
premium it all comes in the same basket
so like Okay so this isn't
self-explanatory
oh can I can I just finish explaining it
I said okay just cook bro just just
speak your mind just say it all right so
in the contract we state that we will
pay you 100 of Google net revenue
right and Google that revenue on page
six is clearly defined in the
definitions as Google ads and Google
subscriptions
okay so now they're like oh well this is
how we Define Google net revenue it's
not everything from Google
we have this tricky little thing so
we're trying to get you on a
technicality
now to anyone listening I hope it's
obvious to you just how unscrupulous
what they're doing is they're clearly
taking money that wasn't intended for
them and justifying it via this really
um
this really kind of uh this this
contract that's written to take
advantage of people
so here they Define Google net revenue
as
uh money received from Google ads
and Google subscriptions with respect to
your content so he's trying so now this
is interesting approach he's taking
these are the only two Revenue products
from Google
for which we we pay you 100
pass-through and we have Ethan we've
paid you on your Google accents and we
generate you
so yeah how [__] generous thanks for
giving my money idiot you expect me to
[__] clap and dance for you because
you paid me my money [__]
hey we fulfilled our end to the bar grin
yeah the deal for you was to do not
steal money from me basically that was
like your whole deal
who wants me to take their money
now you might be wondering why bbtv even
wants us in their Network
if they can't take money they were
putting us in promotional materials and
pamphlets and flyers to court
other people to join their Network and
tweets and social posts you know what I
mean so it was to their great advantage
to have us in their Network
which I regret now because clearly
it was used uh
to to terrible means if this is the way
they do business uh I regret it greatly
that that they were able to do that
so we we've we've we've fulfilled we're
fulfilling our contractual agreement by
paying you 100 of the Google ads and 100
their Google subscription
products dude so now
so he goes it's
clearly defined as ad revenue and
subscriptions what you'll notice here
he's very quick to Define everything
but one thing you'll notice he doesn't
Define is Google subscriptions
let's read what in this contract Google
subscriptions means
Google subscription means a
subscription-based service on YouTube
offered or facilitated by Google whereby
end users May access your videos the
timing and selection of which is at such
end user's discretion and for which the
end user is charged a predetermined
periodic fee to access such content as
often as the end user selects During the
period covered by the fee
for the avoidance of Doubt Google
subscriptions include the Google branded
service YouTube Red which is now YouTube
premium and any successor or replacement
thereof they're not saying
that that's all it is they're saying it
includes that because at the time that
was something a product that existed and
people wanted to know and to carve out
that they weren't taking that money
right because if membership existed they
would have carved I would have made them
carve that in too
so to me how how is membership not a
subscription by even by the way they
defined it like it's literally exactly
that
it's a subscription-based service
facilitated by Google
the timing and selection which is at the
user's discretion
the end user is charged a determinate
fee periodic fee to access content at
their at any period they want that
that's membership that's what it is and
so you'll notice that he doesn't
he doesn't seem interested in defining
Google subscriptions only the other ones
well tell me this
what line justifies you guys to take 30
of membership go ahead and what line in
the contract says you're entitled to
that is that a sponsor that you brought
to us because you're taking it out of a
sponsor that you're brought to us yes
we've talked about stuff like that how
is money from our members something that
you brought to us
I'd like to know
can I ask you a question did you bring
us members
yeah
did you bring us members they come to
our Channel and click the button and the
understanding was clearly that if they
bring us business they get a cut
what happened to that hey yes do you
guys know that we we helped you with
your overall Channel not specifically
you
what how do you help me with my overall
challenge that caught me off guard I was
like the [__] are you even gonna try to
say that dummy help me with my overall
channel
can I can I just explain the contractual
delivery of what we've done on our side
of the clock tell me what part of the
contract entitles you to 30 of my
members Revenue that's paid to me from
YouTube go ahead okay so because that
revenue is captured in
in the definition of other net revenue
on page six how their net revenue on
page again he's trying to get us on a
technicality right skipping over the
fact that it's clearly defined and
Google subscriptions
so let's look at other net revenue so
they're already wrong even by their own
term like it's already GG they're
[__] lying they're wrong Google
subscriptions in your opinion it might
yeah it's all it's written right here
yeah yeah
it's all in my opinion everything I'm
saying here is in my opinion
is defined defines it how is it either
is it by another entity is it like um
stamps.com or like audible audible like
how is it how is it other
so other network other net revenues
basically
a description of all of any other
Revenue products other than other than
Google AdSense Google subscription no so
ignoring the fact that it clearly fits
in the Google subscription let me read
the definition other net revenue for any
period means Revenue earned and received
by bbtv and such period from the
district distribution monetization or
the exploitation of your content
and a matter other than through the sale
of Google ads Google subscriptions
direct ads other platform ads or branded
entertainment arrangement
so it even has an exception for Google
subscriptions oh it says that everything
in this other category yeah I mean right
there yeah it's carved out everywhere
and so they're saying that because it's
not specifically a service that didn't
even exist let me emphasize that when I
signed this contract because it's not
specifically listed
somehow clairvoyantly
than they're entitled to the 70 percent
because at the time when I signed this
contract this was all like okay sure if
you bring me if you bring me ads
if you bring me direct ads if you uh
sell my content at other platforms
whatever yeah you can have a cut of that
I don't give a [__]
there was nothing and this is why the
spirit of the contract in my opinion is
important because
in essence it was if you bring me
something you get a cut
everything I do is mine and this is a
clear violation a
a bad faith violation it's a it's a
dirty dirty trick and in my opinion I
think what happened
is that these networks they know [__]
before the general population does I
think and they knew about memberships
coming down the line in fact YouTube
probably told them all like hey there's
a new product you need to be aware of so
that you know how to talk about it with
your members
and so what bbtv did in my opinion
is that they gathered around
and made this very intentional decision
to say hey this could be a great
opportunity for us to steal in my
opinion a ton of money
for our failing dying business
essentially
dying in your opinion but somewhat
objectively too
yeah I mean their stock price is down go
to go to Max
dude I freaked out there's down 97 when
I saw this I was like I'm never getting
paid I'm never getting paid I'm down 10
today they don't 10 of zero is what I
mean what the [__] is down four it's
down it's down four seven four cents
it's like oh boy they're down four cents
I I don't know what's a better
investment uh uh safe moon or bbtv
Holdings
yeah that's true honestly I think safe
moon is a better investment at this
point I just bought 39 million ships
I genuinely do
awesome and so they I in my opinion this
is just uh speculation
but they came together
with attorneys and the leadership and
said we can we think try to justify this
if we need to because it's not specified
and the contract it didn't exist they
don't expect anyone to really challenge
them because their whole business in my
opinion is strong ripping people off and
then strong arming them and making it
too hard or not worth it to pursue to
get the money back in my opinion I just
out of curiosity went into my uh bank
statement
to check because I I have a membership
on the channel on one of my alternate
accounts so I can
get see the members content to check up
on it for my phone and stuff and it is
charged as Google so Google subscription
oh you're paying Google yeah it says
Google subscription in the app that's
what I'm saying so like they know that
this is bold like I'm being charged for
a subscription from Google thank you
exactly it's like okay it's like it's
almost like mind-numbingly dumb yeah
it's it's almost like see don't it's
hard to rationalize why they decided to
go down this path and the only logical
explanation I can think of is that they
just don't have the money to pay me back
because they're about like six hundred
thirty thousand dollars is like a
significant amount of their on hand
money
yeah very well could be my opinion
so anyway they made this concerted
agreement within the organization in my
opinion to do this to stay steal this
money and the crazy part is that they
didn't tell anyone at least myself I'm
assuming uh although I've heard from
other creators in their Network they
didn't tell them anything there was no
negotiation there was no notification
they just silently
shadyly siphon this money
as it came in
now that alone is so unethical it's so
[__] up like that's plain to see right
I mean what the [__] dude
Rick please ask your lawyer to review
page six yes did the membership program
exist when we signed this contract
did it exist when we signed this
contract
we have we recorded membership Revenue
in 2017 for you
no it didn't even exist what are you
talking about
no I mean yeah so
he's lying to me
I mean could he be what could he be
confusing that with because I have no
idea I can't I don't have that I didn't
have access to the records he's talking
about but I know memberships didn't
existing YouTube premium they seem to
Define that as a membership I have no
idea YouTube I don't know what he's
referring to right but I do know we're
talking about memberships right the
whole point of this yeah memberships
wasn't even launched to 2018. we signed
in 2017. now what's interesting as he
tries to lie to me is that
there was a employee who I want to keep
anonymous
of uh and they were able to confirm on
the call that membership
didn't exist until 2018. so he's
basically just caught straight up
[__] lying to my face God hates Liars
what what do you think about what you're
hearing here
this is anonymous YouTube employee
explains that memberships were
introduced in 2018 therefore doesn't
understand how they could have recorded
that
also there's tons of articles online
saying we're just gonna continue yeah
but it's good it's good because he
couldn't [__] right it just shut him
down you know what I mean like I could
tell him all day long but lie to me no
it's not my intention
you might just lied to me you just lied
to me I'm saying doubled down when I
called you out you said it existed it
did not exist now that we've established
that it doesn't exist via somebody from
YouTube do you want to tell me now that
um
that you guys were just going to skim
that without mentioning anything it
wasn't covered because when we
negotiated it was all YouTube Revenue
was a hundred percent to us so at what
point when they introduced a new
a new
product
right
at what point were you guys just going
to passively take 30 of that happily
silently
[Music]
I know exactly what you're saying you're
gonna try to explain that you guys were
justified in and stealing money from us
because of some other vague [__]
about other so here's what's gonna
happen
okay I'm gonna pause it here because
even in the additional Revenue which
they're trying to use to [__] us
if you go to line three it says seventy
percent of other net revenue or as the
parties may agree upon in writing on a
case-by-case basis
now you might be able to argue or
70 but why would it why would you need
the option if they can just do whatever
they want it's the point of this is to
say that we need to agree upon on a
case-by-case basis in writing before you
steal my [__] money
they did not notify me or anyone as far
as I can tell
so even in their own [__] loopholes
are trying to find they're still wrong
one of the reasons I keep highlighting
um
uh charzad
is that she is in my opinion cleverly
staying uh not dirtying her hands but at
the end of the day she's the one making
this decision this guy is just a fall
guy he's a stooge and I'll tell you what
we're gonna find out the truth Charizard
because I'm gonna depose each and every
[__] one of you and I'll spend twice
as much money to do it as you guys owe
me because I don't give a [__] because
I'm gonna find out some really nasty
[__] about you guys
you know when I when you guys get
deposed and also when we subpoena
records emails
messages it's all going to be there
you're going to be talking to them about
this and charzad I know you're watching
don't erase evidence that's illegal
you might be going to your email now and
saying oh [__] I better erase all my
communications so it seems like I didn't
know anything about this that's illegal
in fact I can subpoena Google
and get the deleted emails from you so
don't bother
and I will that's that's the crazy part
I have the money to do this and I'm
[__] crazy enough to do it that's the
that's the part that's absolutely
[__] nuts right
like I just don't care
you [__] me
you [__] me in the ass charzad
you understand what you did
that's what I do
you [__] a lot of people in the ass
[Music]
you [__] the wrong guy in the ass
foreign
sometimes I like getting that some I in
fact afraid if I keep saying it
sometimes I like to get penetrated
anally that doesn't sound that sounds
that doesn't sound less vulgar that
sounds more vulnerable that sounds way
worse
but uh it was metaphorical but I need
permission first I need I need there
needs to be consent you can't just slip
it in and that's where you [__] up
right I don't wipe my ass bro
so yeah I mean listen charzad you're the
captain okay this guy's just a suit
y'all y'all really think I'm dumb as
hell
yeah but uh
[Music]
I've been I don't wonder if she's been
deposed before it's really unpleasant
especially when you have stuff to hide
because you can't lie in deposition you
have to take an oath
you know I could ask her all kinds of
questions like did you know when did you
decide
as a company
to take this Revenue
was there ever any discussions
internally if you should notify
uh Channel owners
[Music]
because she can't lie about it and will
find the communication are you watching
the sharzat I hope you're sweating
because uh you may have potentially
broken the law and that's what I'm
really after if there's a way to get
criminal charges that's what I'm going
to try to pursue I don't know if I'll be
able to but I'll definitely
I'll definitely be doing both if
possible
God hates liars and I hate liars you
know what I mean Charizard
[Music]
I just don't [__] care
like
this is fun for me don't you understand
that
this is like [__] uh
this is what like turns me on this is
what gets me going Charizard I live off
this [__]
that turns nothing gets me hard like
paying attorneys hundreds of thousands
of dollars it's my favorite pastime I've
literally put my lawyer's
great-grandchildren through college
that turns me off and I don't care
just as if Justice is expensive I'll pay
whatever I need to
unlike you I'm not fake Rich I'm
actually rich
what does that mean well sure her my her
she's has own stock in a company that's
worth like two cents like I think I
don't think she's Rich yeah well that's
fair maybe she's kinda rich but like
I think she's invested in this company
that's all a facade
you know
and by the way I'm gonna absorb her
hairline too
this is just a joke by the way but
here she is giving a speech in two years
from now oh no I know it that's what
happens when you cross me I absorb the
hairline
not a good look Charizard take it from
me I learned that mistake a long time
ago soon
this is gonna be you in a few years it's
gonna know what it's like to be a Baldy
not good all right let's continue let's
get back to the call
[Music]
let's see oh the agreement that we
signed that's what I'm trying no no
you're trying to justify something that
makes no sense in what world do if a new
product is introduced you just decides
to take you decided to take money out of
it without bringing a negotiation
conversation to us you just decided it
on your own because the revenue share
in our agreement under other net reviews
defined it did not exist it didn't exist
so when we made the agreement it was not
included in the agreement it doesn't
initially have to exist really because
initially okay I genuinely thought I
didn't even think about it because our
contract to me was so clear I didn't
even think that they would be taking
that money
it's crazy to me and when you hear him
talking about the justification via the
contract I hope it's so obvious to
everybody
how they know how unjustified this is
that is just straight up theft in my
opinion
it might be entitled for 30 out of my
other company why not
I'm not trying to stimulate a war
between us I'm just trying to explain to
you how the extra
agreement that'll be contractually
signed that's all I I'm not um yes
do you guys know what you're getting
well you should understand what you are
saying though because this is a lot of
money that you guys took without saying
a word to us and we just found out
so you can't just ask so nonchalant
about it we are very serious about it
and this is going to be very serious if
this is the road you want to take
again I'm not I'm not trying to
stimulate a a war because all right you
guys will you guys will hear from our
attorneys this is over and uh I'll have
plenty to say uh not to you guys but uh
obviously our fans are going to know
what happened to 620 000 that they
thought were giving to us that our
network was actually stealing from us
we'll talk about it we will talk about
it
um and but not any longer in this
conversation honestly I was just over it
because it was obvious that the
conversation wasn't we weren't getting
anywhere yeah no they were budging and
um
I was just I was just wasting my breath
but here is my favorite part that comes
up here is he tries to make this really
interesting and potentially cute
justification
so uh uh I was about to hang up [__] you
[__] your company you guys are thieves
and deep down you know you're a thief in
my opinion you're on the phone trying to
justify it but like you know that what
you're doing is that like you know
you're stealing money and I don't know
if it's because bbtv is broke like you
guys just took a 20 million dollar loan
to pay back your [__] bets because
you're incompetent losers they can't run
a [__] business that's possible that
you guys don't even have the money that
was for
that was for what I imagined to be the
room full of leadership sitting in there
with him yeah no I 100 believe yeah yeah
they're they're all yeah on the
conference call yeah but whatever it is
we'll find that out too in Discovery but
what's interesting for to you right is
that you know you're [__] stealing
our money that's what's so interesting
like you're gonna sit here and you're
gonna try to justify it in some vague
other [__] about a program that
didn't even [__] exist and you guys
secretly and quietly skimmed off the top
you know you [__] stole from us and
that's the best part about it like
there's it's indefensible and go back to
your boss what's your name
this was the headline that I love this
is bbtv CEO charzad rafati on why
ethical business decisions are good
business decisions see she's posturing
herself like this altruistic uh she's
just this incredible business well I
mean she's not wrong
now they've done something unethical and
it's probably going to be bad for
business there you go so she was right
she was right she's totally right yes
well said Dan I think okay so maybe
she's maybe she is smarter than I give
her credit for
I can find it right now man what is it
what is it a secret are you not proud of
who you are
uh charad
charad rough body I wouldn't want I
would want to know if she wants to talk
to us before we go down this road if you
want to ask her one more time she wants
to talk to us if you want to reconsider
this
if this is your final episode
do you guys even have the money
Ethan
do you oh that's another okay there was
no okay unfortunately but it's right
it's the same energy yeah yeah right
there Ethan okay Ethan
good question you guys you guys you guys
are
curious how
um okay so this is my favorite part this
is like saying the quiet part out loud
and he really [__] up in my opinion
he really gives away the whole game here
I'm going back a little bit because I
want to make sure that we uh we capture
this moment you guys
how How would how did this surface
um
you guys are on a monthly on a
month-to-month contract with us and you
guys could have walked at any point over
the past two years if you saw this
occurrence and it's being you know
you've been rolling Reggie you're like
you're like a person
what are you saying we were just
cracking up because we're like did you
really [__] just say that I mean he's
blaming us for trusting them right
bro why if you knew that we were
stealing from you why didn't you leave
sooner
yes we robbed you but it's your fault
for not checking yourself you didn't
notice that we were robbing you
we didn't tell you we were robbing you
it's your fault for trusting us don't
you know we're all scumbags shame on you
and he's right essentially he is right
funnily enough but I don't think he's
supposed to say that out loud
like I said there was an unfortunate
situation with our last head of Finance
where she was supposed to check this and
she didn't so he is right you know
but uh he's like listen we exist to
steal as much money from you as possible
if you didn't notice that that's on you
in my opinion
um this is great yeah people are posting
Google subscriptions Google
subscriptions
what the [__] dude HD podcast membership
it's literally in Google subscriptions
you guys it's literally right there
it's right there you guys bro we can't
play it it's current it's cursed
I've just this is funny because it's so
absurd you [__] idiots you dumb
[__]
idiots
really went down this road
and try to tell me a reoccurring payment
in Google subscriptions tab is not a
Google subscription okay geniuses
yes it's my fault for trusting you guys
[Music]
a pile of money you know and my friends
come over and just take it out of there
I could have locked it like what a
[__] idiot am I for not locking up my
money so my friends couldn't come in and
take it off the top I mean how silly of
me not to walk my [__] money up but
you know you're making it so easy for me
I'm gonna get some easy questions did
you did your did you and your legal team
reviews
I'm just asking the question did you
have people realize
did you realize how easy you're making
this
that's your best argument to justify
this why didn't you I'm just I'm just
asking you a question I'm just trying to
understand well I will say I don't know
I don't know if you represent the CEO in
your end like so before I get to ELO's
great Point here
just I mean it your subscription from
Google Commerce
H3 podcast membership subscription Auto
renewing
five euros a month
um
he whiz man here's another one I mean I
it's obvious but I just want them to
know Channel membership H3 podcast
subscriptions
says everywhere subscriptions every
platform
every device
it's defined clearly in the contract
they're like no it's not subscriptions
it's memberships the thing that didn't
exist at the time
hey dummies how does it feel to be so
[__] dumb
hey dummies watching this how stupid do
you feel right now Dom
like just take a moment and realize
sharzad everything you built over all
these years has led you to this moment
[Music]
right where you try to steal money from
me and the result of this is likely to
be the bankruptcy of your company and
potentially criminal charges will be the
cherry on top but we'll see probably not
you know these things are hard it's hard
to prosecute people white-collar crimes
this dude steals or this woman steals
630 000 from me good luck
you know if I steal a Twix from the uh
Circle K going to jail for 10 years
[Music]
it's disgusting
you know how many twicks you could buy
with 630 thousand dollars
probably about 630 000.
that's like 1.2 million Twix
[Music]
charzat look at the face this is the
face that you [__] over
take a deep look into it oh I'm being
told this is actual this is actual face
I'm so sorry Ethan all right
so not the prettiest face but it is a
face
[Music]
you [__] me
you understand what that means
you didn't think I would play this call
did you I don't [__] care
I don't arrest me
I will I'll die for this [__]
[Music]
you know what I mean
I'm just um
this is it
and here you are trying to say it's not
a Google subscription like
all this for that you're gonna throw
away everything you've built for that
[Music]
little Halloween spooks
yeah
you know
and now look oh now you're gonna have to
be deposed you're going to be subpoenaed
you're gonna have to pay lawyers it's
expensive to defend
it's expensive to Sue it's expensive to
defend I know
you know
[Music]
all this for that I mean geez Louise
but it's all in the call you know
so here here's Ela when she clarifies
that uh
uh
something really important again buy
this why didn't you
I'm just I'm just asking you a question
I'm just trying to understand well I
will say I don't know I don't know if
you represent the CEO in your end like
what you're telling us today is that a
representation of what she would want
for your company as well have you guys
talked about it before and this is the
final answer or do you want to bring
this topic to her
okay we reviewed this with our legal and
finding our Council and finance and and
our finance teams right and I'm happy to
have I I I will obviously have a
follow-up call with with Charizard to
explain yeah I think I think she should
know I think she should know before you
guys go into this she should know what
you guys are getting yourself into oh
wait he knows you love he knows I don't
think she knows
so ela's so smart because again she's
really trying to keep her hands clean
yet of course she is the captain of this
boat
and um
either keeps saying because they're
they're trying to claim in the lawyer
letters they sent me they're like well
you acted unrationally and you didn't
give us enough time and they're really
being dishonest right and it's a
strategy because we gave him the whole
week
to come together and bring us this
decision
and she's been involved in my opinion
based on the way he's responding she's
been involved the whole time
it passed through Legal Financial the
head of partnership management and
somehow the CEO is just oblivious to all
this [__] no
she knows they
frankly
think they spent it paying themselves
so they don't have a [__] income they
just pay themselves
I was proud you know what to be fair Ela
I was probably the single biggest source
of income for their own business and
[__] over the past few years
and how else
this this was just an aside with me and
Eli you know what I mean we were just
chatting at this point
he just happens to be on the call with
us you know what I mean like where I
don't know where that money's coming
from
I'm glad you want you guys open but the
yeah go ahead yeah I know I was just
gonna say Ethan just to keep this
constructive on a billboard well no why
don't we just
nope
so we will schedule we'll schedule a
call with with
um on on Monday if if you're okay with
that
went home sorry
we'll
set up a call this is this is what they
do they just delay they delay
they put off this is like a well-known
tactic right when you owe someone money
yeah you delay delay put off Kick the
Can their intentions are clear
very clear here and we we say that if
there's no if you guys aren't paying us
back I don't want to [__] talk to you
that's the thing I just I don't know
that we can spend talking we can't spend
a lot of time on this so I mean you can
send us an email you know just let us
know in email I mean if it's gonna be
the same answer we're we're not going to
want to spend more time on this so you
can let us know in email if anything
changes
and hopefully before Monday morning
because we have a show in which we're
gonna want to talk about this right oh
yeah I'm definitely want to explain it
in great detail actually yeah uh uh
absolutely they did and here we are how
do I say your name
I look forward to our future friendship
together I do too
I'm very excited
uh you're cool I like you I'm talking to
my my direct rep who's like very low
down the totem pole he was the only guy
who was admitting to being on that call
and that I think I cut it out in the
beginning for brevity and also I didn't
want to
say his uh name part of such a [__]
disgusting uh group of criminals I would
drop
leave the sinking ship now they're
obviously on the verge of bankruptcy if
they're stealing money from us and
taking 20 million loans
you start looking for a new job you're
better than this
I appreciate the call Ethan yeah we'll
follow up as soon as we can with next
steps
fantastic like what a great call what a
great call Fantastic love you guys all
right Lord
appreciate it
so I knew I was like all right these
[__] really want to go down
this road I see a lot of people saying
and I I had the same opinion myself why
would they possibly choose this path
instead of just paying me back
the only plausible explanation I can
think of is that they don't have the
money right I mean like
because like how the [__] did they think
that this would go their way
well like I said at the beginning of the
show
um you know it seems like
part of their business model is
exploiting creators trust and our
husband for a long time in our opinion
and
and frankly I think they've probably
just been getting away with it for so
long I think yeah it may be right but it
could be it could be a money thing too
because when you look at their stock
it's like obviously the company's in
trouble and how did it happen thousand
dollars it's 620 000. but I think you're
right I think people complain about
being exploited to them on a daily basis
from what I've seen this is like routine
for them
yeah you might even say the real
business is writing exploitative
contracts
that would be an opinion that you could
hold you might say that I do say that in
my opinion
so after this call
I immediately realized
okay I've been putting off this thing
I'm gonna get demonetized for two weeks
potentially but I I have to leave like I
don't have a [__] choice
and I was on the phone with people from
YouTube they're trying to figure out the
best and most painless way to do this
I had to make a new AdSense located in
the United States
so I cancel my AdSense account and I
make a new one and then that's when
everyone got notified that the
memberships were paused right
so this channel was completely
demonetized the memberships were paused
for like a day
and I'm so grateful that I I don't know
if my dude was able to expedite it and
that's what happened because it like in
the middle of the night it started
working again
um
so shout out to them that's awesome
swelling was like unmonetized for a day
and then so that's when everyone started
to get confused and worried
and genuinely
did not expect to turn this into like a
big viral thing I made this video to
tell everybody on the subreddit and on
Twitter and stuff and Discord were like
what happened
you know and I don't I I they deserve to
know I mean this is their money so I
posted this video
bbtv stole 620 000 on my you know my my
dumb stupid whatever Channel
and this was like a really dry long
video
I did not expect
at this to actually become a thing at
all I really didn't but it went I don't
know how many points did you get on
Reddit I didn't go to the comments
because I heard that everyone there is a
super meanie who told you that
oh I saw people in the suburb being like
why does everybody hate Ethan on our
videos oh I don't know maybe early on
because when I saw it I just saw it
organically I opened Reddit oh really on
the top of my feed with like 20 000
upvotes was your video on our videos and
when I went to the comment section uh it
was mostly just talking about like yep
mcns once again okay yeah it seems well
that's yeah I don't know I didn't really
see any hate that's good I'm too fragile
for Reddit comments these days I gotta
keep this facade of confidence uh I
guess it's probably for the best yeah
yeah it's not healthy but I I I I went
into the okay let's admire for you and
it seemed fine that's nice and at 22.3
000 upvotes so a lot of people saw that
on Reddit
uh what I said in this is a lot of what
we've already talked about there's
actually one moment here where I did a
little edit maybe I'll just play it for
you guys because I had fun with it but
it was after this video started getting
traction on Reddit when they got freaked
out and started sending me lawyer
letters okay
oh this is It's just uh this email that
I already read so whatever
as far as December I just put like sad
[__] overly even earlier the total
amount withheld from us whatever
it was fun I had fun doing it there was
the uh
Lion King we did a you know a third
party sponsorship in which case your
company would see receive a cut of that
specific Revenue
it has become apparent that this
understanding has not been respected and
I am deep learned about crying there
further yeah yeah yeah this video you
sent me down this tripped me out I'd
never seen it this must have been a joke
right gravity of this matter the kid
freaking kid freaking out yeah uh I
believe it did end up being actually I
don't remember because that that was a
viral video years ago it was fake and
I'm glad because I felt really bad if
that was real that was pretty brutal
um so I made that video it went pretty
big on Reddit it really wasn't my
intention I swear to God I thought
people on our Reddit would just watch it
and just so they could know what
happened
so that's when I started hearing from
bbtv
I people started contacting me
and saying that the same thing happened
to them uh Brody Fox
here's a few examples
Brody fox says we have the same contract
100 YouTube Revenue with bbtv from 2017.
same deal I had they've been taking 70
of our membership as well didn't notice
until now since it's a small amount we
don't actively push it on our viewers
but I imagine other creators have been
affected so that's why I was like oh
this is like a company-wide policy that
they decided on in my opinion
speculative
here's a comment from the uh
from the subreddit I thought was great
he goes I have the same agreement
um I'm reviewing it it wouldn't surprise
me uh if this was being done to more and
then edit yet they've been taking 30
percent
damn
busted
cavos said I see I didn't even know this
happened
apparently
well I'll read this I've been in bbtv
for five years every month on the 15th
of each month I've been paid for five
years today everyone receives this email
telling us one day before being paid
that the payout has been moved to next
month
and I've seen this ship before and I
know what where this is going
yeah like what is that so this really
freaked me I was like oh these guys are
bankrupt they don't have any money yeah
that's not a good sign I was like what
the [__] seriously and so here this is
the email he got
hi kavos as you may have seen over the
past week a number of banking
institutions and affiliate Payment
Solutions have been affected by recent
Market events
while bbtv has no affiliation with
affected banking institutions like SVP I
was like okay then
what's the problem who cares they go oh
we understand that many creators are
concerned about the situation and may
seek to update their payment details I
was like are you [__] kidding me yeah
I'm sure a ton of creators have uh
checking accounts with this specialty
bank that finances Silicon Valley
startups exclusively
[Music]
you know we just didn't want to send it
to
God forbid
we had to delay the payments
in case anyone wanted to change it based
on these events if you wish to change
the bank account we send payments dude
please advise us at your earliest
convenience it's not chase that went
under dude
it's not Wells Fargo
in an effort to avoid potential
processing delays associated with these
impacts across a range of partner
payment vendors bbtv is updating your
payment shows they go in order to avoid
delays we are delaying your payment by
three weeks
[Music]
under this new payment schedule in line
with our payment terms you will be paid
one week following the end of the month
for example your January 2023 earnings
will now be paid April 7th instead of
March 15th
a month
a little bit less but yeah
so but this is kind of their MO is like
this little like
corporate poisonous [__] Cherry
[__] that pisses me off while we
recognize this change may cause initial
inconvenience for some creators it is
part of our commitment to ensure the
ongoing timeliness of partner payments
by delaying it
yeah what
so this really sketched me out yeah
I was like oh brother these guys are
[__]
they're broke as hell boy
uh let's see so there was oh wait there
was more no that was it and then uh
let's see
there was also this a bunch of
interesting other stuff came out just to
give you an idea
this guy reached out to me a big
YouTuber Cipher PK
he said I had a situation with this
company in 2018 I ended up having to
take legal action just to leave my
contract and had to agree that I
wouldn't ask them for the nearly 20K
they owed me
so that's why this is routine this is
like their whole business
he elaborated in DMS and gave me
permission to share this message he said
in 2018 I had to dispute with them I was
on 100 split but they defaulted me to 80
40.
which is ridiculous for a Channel of my
size and once I realized it was short
20K and was stuck on that contract I got
my lawyers involved the best deal I
could get was to terminate the contract
immediately
but signed an agreement that I can't go
after the 20K anymore I didn't want the
hassle so they probably locked them into
like a year and they're like we'll
release you but we're keeping the money
scumbags crazy that's that's this is the
ethical business
that
charzad rafati is running this was in
2018 just you know
Cavo said yeah I tried off-boarding
before they took any new payments
from my channel but they didn't respond
and ignored me I'm worried I won't ever
see this money you know I tried to
unlink my uh video my are they did we
get unlinked yet Dan
let me take a look
so this is even more [__] up listen to
this
day still pending
scumbags
oh yeah okay this is actually great hey
I hope you guys are watching we asked
chatgpt4 our YouTube members considered
a subscription
this is Case Closed yes YouTube
memberships are considered a form of
subscription
say less
I'll I won't read the I'll pause it so
you all can read that at home
idiots dumbass [__] losers stupid
morons ruining your whole business for
this moronic [__] criminal in my opinion
scumbag scum buckets
um
yes so
to unlink my channel from them
I have to request permission on the
dashboard and as you can show Dan you
can show that image I need them
graciously to accept
my request
and they can just keep me in there as
long as they want because they got to
click that [__]
and as long as they don't click that
[__] guess what my money all my money's
going to them
money that I may potentially never see a
hundred percent of it if they go
bankrupt
and it's kind of crazy that YouTube
like allows the money to go to them
like they should be in my opinion
YouTube should be stopping all payments
to Broadband TV
until they figure this [__] out because
that money
I am speculating
based on what I'm seeing could just be
going into the black hole bankruptcy and
none of these creators ever get paid
same thing happened in defy media
I don't know if I mentioned that today
you did earlier yeah I didn't show it
this happened this has precedent
God damn it
they've disappeared stop suddenly
stopped paying all the creators
why am I not playing
is it not defy media
[Music]
spell right to fight media and MCN
uh closing
here it is
they're shutting down suddenly they just
stop paying people they own CR they owed
creators like 1.7 million dollars and
just bailed with it
I think in that case YouTube compensated
everybody who got robbed
but in this case but in this case I
don't know it's going to be a lot more
than 1.7 million followers because this
guy these guys just recruit all day long
check your emails even if you have 10
Subs you got an email from bbtv trying
to talk to your parents
foreign
so yeah I'm waiting on the good grace of
them to disconnect me so they can't
steal my money anymore YouTube says they
can't do anything about it which I find
hard to believe
[Music]
because there's a clause in the contract
for unauthorized unlinking and the
penalty for that
is just ten thousand dollars
so I'm like okay I accept the penalty
unlink me
but they they don't
like I can't leave that's [__] up and
what world can you not leave a contract
it's like no I want to break the
contract I've made the decision to break
it
but I but they I can't I literally can't
I have no control over this situation
I have no agency I can't do anything to
expedite this I can't do anything to
mitigate losses
it's solely in their Court to to cancel
my my relationship with them
which doesn't make sense they've proven
that they're bad actors so
you can't handcuff me to them they've
gone Rogue they're [__] up
they cannot be trusted
like I talked to my guys at YouTube they
go it's contractual I says yeah but like
in the real world I can walk away from a
contract I can break the contract
bottom line is you cannot be trusted
it's crazy it's like handcuffed it's
like
it's like the house is on fi it's like
I'm under house arrest and the house is
burning down they're like you can't
leave
you're under house arrest you can't
leave no I accept there was I'm gonna
leave the house you can put me back in
jail I don't want to die
they're like no you can't leave house
arrest
this is what's happening
this guy there's a bunch of people that
have a bunch of [__] problems with
them
they're like claiming this guy's videos
out of turn we know what they're
skimming off him
this was similar to what love was saying
I made a video about this years ago when
I was screwed over by them I was 17 or
18 at the time and when I signed with
them
all I uh all they did was steal my money
and give nothing a return you gotta love
that when I tried to leave they forced
me to stay that's their whole business
it's endless I mean honestly I'll I want
to move on because there's the lawyer
letters are good
so this is the kind of stuff I'm hearing
um
it's no surprise to me
so that evening after I put out the
video
I get their first uh letter from their
attorney
and this is where ice the fun really
begins
see they don't think that I'm gonna
share this but I am like oops like I I
don't care
they go private and confidential [__]
that
I don't agree
but I don't care about that my life's an
open book
it's not my [__] problem
well you don't want to hear about 9 11.
well stated
these people are they don't they just I
don't care well you don't want to hear
about 9 11. you don't want to hear about
attention Ethan Klein Dear Mr Klein
further
to your meeting with our team on Friday
we have been assessing your comments
with our legal and operational teams
while we have been doing this we have
been made aware of your videos and
Twitter posts
we believe that these are extremely
unhelpful
yeah to who
exactly unhelpful
yeah I'm crazy like that I'm being super
unhelpful
and we also believe they contain
defamatory content I was like okay
you guys want to do that you guys want
to be like posture in that way cause I'm
not a [__] kid I know what defamation
is
[Music]
so then this is where they start lying
to me and manipulating what happened
they says and this is why I'm so glad we
recorded the call they says we would
like to investigate your concerns fully
but we need time to do this thoroughly
and without the distraction and the
unhelpful backdrop
they had a week
I notified them as I showed you in the
beginning politely
I came to them
willing to accept that it was an honest
mistake
and when they got on the phone with me
and spit in my face and told me they're
keeping the money
now it's like well you didn't give us
the time
and you're acting like put your granny
Griff right you're not giving us the
time and you're just acting rashly no
no you had the time and you made your
[__] choice
please remove the videos and tweets
posted yesterday and today and refrain
from further comment until we have been
able to discuss this with you and your
Council or what
[Music]
what are you gonna do about it
everybody's got
his good plans
please remove the post and stop talking
about it or what I'm here live
I couldn't even you couldn't even erase
this if you tried
what the [__] are you gonna do about it
[Music]
I'm unhelpful as [__]
my middle [__] name that's right
that's a fact stop me
stop me why aren't you helping them
steal help them out I wish you would be
more helpful man can you be my body stop
me you think's so tough I know
me Mr unhelpful nothing's fun anymore
I'm right here stop me
what the [__] are you gonna do about it
we are working to give you a considered
and detailed response by Wednesday of
next week again delay delay delay kick
the guy I told you guys about this
[__] this week early gave you the
entire week and now you need to
Wednesday to give a detailed response
after you spit my face [__] no I'm not
gonna sit around like a dumbass while
you guys embezzle my money in my opinion
as you guys prepared the paperwork for
bankruptcy I'm gonna sit in my opinion
this speculation I'm just gonna sit
around and let you steal my money [__]
you stop me
please I'm begging you stop me
in the meantime if you have legal
counsel involved in this matter please
provide them with a copy of this letter
and have them get in touch with me as
soon as possible nah [__] you
here's the thing they're in Canada so I
need to find a Canadian attorney
the one that my main lawyer suggested
actually has a conflict so he can't
um
you can't represent us
so now I have to find a Canadian
attorney but this is just me and you
lady I'm free balling
it's just me and you I bet you're used
to talking to attorneys who are very
cordial and they're very careful and it
I don't know
it's just me
and I'm [__] crazy
it's me here's my response
this is the first of two email exchanges
we had
I said
dear whatever her name is
I must find a Canadian attorney I have a
good reference I can follow up on Monday
if you would like me to erase my post
you can provide me the full amount owed
and unleash me from the network not
because my posts aren't true but because
I'd rather be done with this sooner than
later I'm not going to remove it on some
vague promise to get back to me on
Wednesday
I believe everything I've said to be
true and accurate and when appropriate
clearly labeled as opinion in terms of
being defamatory this is something for a
judge or jury to decide but as I'm sure
you know truth is the best defense to
defamation and that is certainly on my
side sorry you all got to face
consequences for being shady pieces of
[__] they get so up in arms they're like
no don't talk about us
they're like a vampire with light on
them ah no
fighting defamation cases is practically
a sport for me at this point
nothing excites me like an opportunity
to strengthen our first amendment rights
or Free Speech as guaranteed in your
fair Canadian Charter
additionally it's worth mentioning that
I plan to talk extensively about this on
Monday show including the recording of
the call with your lovely representative
this letter as well
so if it is your intention to remedy
this please let me know by end of day
tomorrow or at least let me know by
Monday 12 PM PST
let me check
well my rep asked did PBT
remove you
no they still
have no either they said they would
today
yep they still haven't
so that was mine I made my intentions
very clear I'm like listen this is all
going up and she you know what I mean am
I being clear
I'm being clear wait even on their own
website
wait are you [__] kidding me bbtv.com
channel memberships
see a timestamp
today wait what the timestamp at the top
left says today they made this today
whoever made this oh saying that it was
updated today oh they just added this
huh sneaky
sneaky little sneaky boys working in
behind the scenes huh
trying to cover your ass
it's too late for that
too late for that [__] boy
am I being clear
so okay nice update so then that's the
first round we had
now on that evening they made it to
abundantly clear to me
that uh
they were not going to be able to
resolve this to my satisfaction they
sent me another legal letter that
evening
by the way both of these
she sent to me at like 10 30 p.m I was
like oh yeah
that sounds like they're having a really
fun time right now
another one on the weekend on East on
Easter weekend you sent this to me on
Easter weekend at 10 30 p.m working late
so as this one says uh hi Ethan I
realize you will be seeking counsel
tomorrow given the urgency and the
absence I am sending this note to you
well thank you who else would you send
it to I'm right here with you let's
dance
it is very it's very disappointing to
see that after working together for five
years you have decided to breach
YouTube's Community guidelines
so she's threatening to nark on me to
YouTube for some vague like
she's she's threatening to give me a
strike somehow dummy you think I'm dumb
they've continued to treat me like an
idiot
after five years of working together you
decide to breach YouTube's Community
guidelines our content provider
agreement and defame and harass our
company and our CEO when you have been
receiving clear and itemized Revenue
share summaries from bbtv every single
month properly reflecting your contract
with the company since the beginning of
our partnership again more of the same
they're like yo
you trusted us for this long dummy it's
on you
obviously harassing and defaming they're
trying to use big scary words and this
works most of the time though Community
guidelines oh they're going to get me in
trouble the fame and harass uh
I'm scared
yeah do something about it
dude I'm freaking scared go ahead I'm
right here you got my address you know
everything about me
let's go
we are always available to work with
creators to answer any questions
took you three days to get back to me
regretfully you gave us no opportunity
to have a meaningful conversation or to
work constructively with you again
this is revision [__] [__] you
you had three you had a whole week to
come together and make that decision to
[__] me in the ass
without Lube
rude and I will depose you all and I
want to hear that conversation about if
we should use Lube or not I will make
sure our lawyer asks you while you're
being deposed charzad did you say you
would
do sodomy on Ethan
without the use of a lubricant
I will ask that
and we'll get to the truth
amazing instead you have maliciously
attacked our company
our CEO and team and potentially
illegally recorded a conversation with
our business representative okay come
get me come arrest me
and you've also crossed other important
legal and contractual boundaries it's
like
say what they are hey here come come
come get me and you broke a whole bunch
of other rules that I'm not gonna write
right now
[Music]
yeah you guys know what's disappointing
that you stole 620 000 for me
due to the approach you've taken
we can confirm that you have clearly
contravained YouTube Community
guidelines and breached your agreement
with bbtv and hence we are releasing
your channel and terminating our
relationship with us as of Tuesday April
11th oh that's tomorrow
that's tomorrow my guy why are they
waiting it's like why just do it now
it's Monday do it now
okay so they say tomorrow
we're waiting
but I'm already my YouTube guy
okay if you're so if you are interested
in resolving the remainder of what
appears to be a contractual dispute
I love that it's just a contractual
shoot they're like the contract could
say anything
and they'll be like no we're keeping
your money because uh hey it's a I don't
know there's something in the contract
that says we can take it up with the
judge
just legal theft
something about I don't know and three
two something about other Revenue I
don't know I'm keeping it
forget about it
if you're interested in resolving this
contractual dispute please be advised
that we will make our team available
discuss these concerns if you continue
to publicly harass our team
and inform the Creator misinformed the
Creator Community about our company we
will hold you accountable
I want you to hold me accountable
we can assure you that bbtv is alive and
well and supporting thousands of
Partners we are proud of the work that
we do with the Creator community and of
thousands of creators who appreciate and
trust us so this is when I
I got this letter late at night I
immediately went to the basement
and I said
okay
cracked my Knuckles
[__] my basement sat down for like
an hour plus and I said all right this
is the one this is the one by the way
this is a pretty good name bbtv uh
headquarters and Ethan's opinion
so I was like okay okay
so here is my mag magnum opus
is that right
that's right
thank you
so I put together something pretty
pretty special to me
so here it is
tip take a sip
is it legible or is it just the screen
there
I have it on low bandwidth mode so it's
more legible and okay what's being
streamed so I said dear whatever
attorney I must express my deepest
gratitude for the fact that this is the
second legal letter you've sent me at
the witching hour of 10 pm on a weekend
no less and during a holiday to boot
happy Easter by the way truly warms my
heart to know that you're so devoted to
our little dispute that you're willing
to sacrifice your precious personal time
it paints a rather Vivid picture of
frantic desperation as if you're
scrambling to make amends for your
company's own incompetence
if you intend to accuse me of violating
YouTube's Community guidelines and
defaming and harassing your CEO I would
kindly request that you be more specific
it's crucial that we maintain a fair and
transparent dialogue during this time
fair and transparent unlike your theft
of 620 000 without notice or discussion
while I am truly heart broken by the end
of our relationship
I cannot help but wonder if your company
will be able to survive without the
steady flow of stolen fronts from our
Channel
it is indeed a trying Time For You
especially considering that your stock
has plummeted a staggering 96 percent
not to mention the recent acquisition of
21.6 million Canadian dollars
desperately sought to pay off mounting
debts 21. and my God to accept that loan
with 16 interest
how bad are your financials a kid with a
lemonade stand could secure better
financing from the childhood than the
neighborhood children
if you needed money you only had to ask
I would have given it to you for 15
percent
by the way 16 is horrible that is crazy
in your letter
you accuse me of potentially illegally
recording a conversation with your
business representative and Crossing
other unspecified legal and contractual
boundaries however as you are well aware
Canada is a one-party consent country
I'm sure the important legal and
contractual boundaries I crossed are
very scary
apparently to speak of since you cannot
even list them unlike you I can be very
specific about the legal and contractual
boundaries you have crossed stealing 620
thousand dollars
the notion that I was somehow impatient
and unwilling to wait for your decision
is provably false you're Grant an entire
week to carefully consider the matter
after receiving my initial letter and
ultimately chose and you know in unison
with leadership to retain my funds
this decision is clearly documented in
the recorded call which fortunately
exists to counter your misrepresentation
of the facts
resolving this issue is quite
straightforward on your point return the
stolen 620 000. anything less will be
for the courts to decide
lastly I couldn't help but notice the
closing paragraph of your letter in
which you profess your undying pride in
your company
well I'm thrilled to see you so enamored
with your organization it did come
across as slightly insecure
P.S as an aside considering the current
state of affairs at your company it
might be wise a wise decision to explore
new employment opportunities I'm sure
your skills and expertise as a lawyer
would be highly valued somewhere else
for example
FTX Enron or the Capone crime family
your obedient servant Ethan Klein your
obedient servant definitely a Hamilton
yes a Hamilton reference and and I'm
gonna and she she always when she
messages me
she does an attachment
she always puts it in attachment so I
wanted to put something in an attachment
for her so I said please see the
attached image
and uh here's what I attached
um it's a picture of
[Laughter]
does [__] you and your whole
organization it's a picture of me soy
eyed and just a little something because
she should know
a little bit about me it's a minion meme
I'm a handful I'm strong-willed
independent a bit outspoken and I tell
it like it is I make mistakes I am
sometimes out of control and at times
I'm hard to handle but I love and I give
with all my heart so true if you can't
handle me at my worst then you sure
don't deserve me at my best signed
owner fair use and First Amendment
Advocate Ethan Klein a proper title
I'm also never gonna get over and on a
holiday weekend to boot
such a good choice of words I was sad
like it was obviously so sad that they
were that she was writing me that then
yeah
and that pretty much brings us up to
speed that's the whole story wow that's
the Saga so far
um I haven't heard from them
this was the last one I sent this to her
last night
and uh this is where it is so
um their entire
their entire argument hinges on the fact
that memberships is not a subscription
and like
come on it I mean come on is it a
recurring payment is it once a month you
can charge the same amount I mean does
it get cut off if you stop paying it's a
subscription I'm sorry no no no no it's
other Revenue other
it wasn't specified
so uh that's where we are now in my
opinion what's going to happen now
well they're definitely not paying me
back
so
which is annoying but I need to sue them
and uh
let's go they might try to sue me but I
don't care I'm just spitballing here I
don't know nothing about nobody but um
with the fact that already there are
other creators uh coming out of the
woodwork saying they did the exact same
thing is there any uh benefit to making
this like a class action thing I don't
think so classic class actions don't
really work like that it's like
it has to be like the same exact crime
same exact details and they're all be
different
Prime you know crime
um
so I'm definitely not getting the money
back there I I really
I don't think they're gonna survive I
think they want to sue me but I don't
think they even have the money to do it
like it's so expensive to do that I
don't even think they have it
so I'm gonna assume they're probably
gonna declare bankruptcy before I can
get the money but that's okay it's been
worth it I would love charzad
to be the one it'd be worth it for you
to have taken the 620 for me to bankrupt
you that'd be worth it to me I'd happily
I'd be like you know what
it was worth it I'm happy that money's
gone
I'm happy
I'm [__] stoked about this whole
thing
[Music]
you know
so I don't know that that's where we are
[Music]
any comments any questions I don't know
pretty crazy though right it's like come
on [__] hoes so would this be in
Canadian Court yes that's why I have to
get a Canadian okay attorney they're
located in Canada and the contract says
it needs to be
[Music]
um it needs to be resolved in Canadian
jurisdiction whatever the [__] so
I got a question go ahead on my H3
podcast bingo card I got Ethan his suit
again this is this discount if you sue
them uh they might counter soup no they
have to assume me this sucks dude but I
think you have a good shot at that if
they counter Sue I would say you guys oh
yeah yeah if they counter Sue yeah okay
there's so there's hope y'all really
think like I'm just cool dude like if
I'm not being sued by five people at
once it feels weird right I'm
comfortable I'm only comfortable when
I'm being sued by like at least 10
people at once so thank you guys for
just putting me in my comfort zone
by the way we had some massive gifts
during that that I really want to thank
bbno wait BB no money so okay just to
clarify it is not really BB no money I
thought it was at first I went and
checked the channel and it was like a 30
subscriber thing and I noticed that
their name their icon is the bbtv icon
so they're making a pun they're saying
BBT that's funny that is funny it's our
original it's the members wait bbtv no
don't pay me back via subscriptions you
can you pay me back just send me a wire
right I did this this person gave 1 100
Subs it's the same guy that's uh as
before members go off it's members
yep
I confirmed it directly so wow that's so
that is so nice and what's so awesome
about that is that the memberships go to
you guys in the chat
it's like so cool how that works and now
we all get to hang out on Saturday
and walk enjoy watching uh a b beat the
[__] out of some old Loser yeah that's
right
and uh Eden Ray was another one uh
donated 300 amazing members so much and
uh
I'm sorry Halo
[Applause]
Halo hopefully I'm saying that right uh
gifted 50. thank you guys it's so nice
oh so appreciated
by the way I've been through this so
many times
this I'll tell you exactly what they're
gonna do they'll be like Ethan used to
show the fundraise and therefore we're
owed that money
I I've seen it so many times it's like
okay next
they'll definitely do that if they sue
me right
uh
well
there it is you know there it is in all
honesty this [__] so annoying that I
have to deal with this [__] now like
it's so annoying why does this keep
happening to me I'm just minding my own
[__] business
it's a simple country lawyer I may not
know much but I am just a simple country
lawyer simple country podcaster that's
right
I just why do I have to be the one to
always deal with this [__]
grandpa is feeling a little frisky today
well again because I mean it's in a
weird way you are privileged to be able
to even take this fight on you know
um and I think that's part of it it's a
combination of you have the you have the
ability to fight something like this
which a lot of people don't and like you
laid out you're psycho yeah I'm like
mentally ill I must be right so between
those two things they picked the worst
possible person they could have pulled
this on so there you go but in all
honesty this sucks like do you guys
doing a lawsuit is so much work on my
point I know you pay the lawyers a lot
but you have to get so much in order for
them and then you know it's just it's a
lot of time and I don't want to [__]
do this but obviously
I have to you have no choice just when
he thought you were out you pull you
back you pull me back in for one last
job damn it dude
uh my guy's saying ask bbtv for an exact
time I'm gonna do that right now
okay I'll wait I'll wait but I'm not
sure uh I mean there's other stuff but
God damn uh we've been here for three
hours okay so I should probably wrap it
up
uh lots to talk or lots to say for
Wednesday I suppose but tomorrow is
members podcast so it'll be fun to be
there with a lot of you all new members
thank you to the generous generous gifts
and thank you there's a lot of
individual um
people who watch oh yeah let's watch
Philly D's coverage
uh sure let me uh I wanted to rate his
uh grab the time stamp hopefully this
doesn't upset you he's gonna he's gonna
99.9 be on your side but make one
comment
be like this part is unclear and we'll
have to wait for more information and
Philly's dead to us again let's see
we'll see we'll see we got some good
hopeful uh
hopeful leads that it's going to be good
but yeah so members tomorrow's our
members only podcast see you next
Tuesday it'll be fun
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
or just the time stamp at the end I just
he kind of sums it up at the end so I
just I time stamped that
uh I'll watch the whole thing I just hit
the button by the way well they know you
don't have to tell them I love that
button I love the button I looked over
and everyone's like dude
it's so I was actually about to hit it
you were gonna be man you beat me to
them oh we got the bread the bull button
screen too this is great
oh they just saw the Brad one yeah nice
imaginary
love me that button man this button is
going to save my life oh yeah it already
has it already has all right let's watch
Philip all right so let's see what when
it very plainly and clearly states that
it is part of normal YouTube net revenue
that's ultimately where we are with this
we have to wait to see what happens but
hopefully okay Philly you're really
gonna use that old picture of me looking
fat as hell
I think it's from like a week ago I'm
just trying the spring background you
both look Gorge I'm trying to find
something
look at the beautiful sisters on the
screen right now not as beautiful as
Phil he looks amazing glowing
Ethan and any other Creator effective
God he looks so good good for him man
it's stunning though so cool how how how
he's transformed himself looks great or
made whole cause this is [__] insane
because based up thank you so far it
seems like the situation is plain as day
and then the Super Mario Bros movie
absolutely destroyed well that's good
well we skipped to the end I mean he did
it looks like it's the main segment of
the show oh I want to watch it I gotta
look for any little [__] song it's if
you it's there's uh time stamps so you
should see where it begins I got it
right here yeah I went to the chapters
I'm watching with the eagle live Philly
got my eye on you nine of the H3 podcast
now reportedly suing Broadband TV but
not yet not yet but I will be
for sure I will be one is bbtv where
it's a bbtv describes itself as a
Creator and content management company
or as Ethan described it a multi-channel
network with Ethan explaining even
though he's always been skeptical about
trusting multi-channel networks he said
he actually had to use one to get paid
from YouTube and even explaining this is
because you're only allowed to have one
AdSense account at a time and Ethan made
his while living in Israel but he was
he's good at summarizing it really fast
yeah I will tip he's he's crushing it
that man is like he's an Auctioneer boy
so far so good he's a fast stalker and
we like that it's cutting right to the
chase wasn't allowed to change his
country something that made it
impossible for him to get money directly
from YouTube so he decides to work with
bbtv so YouTube pays them first and then
they give the money to him and this
evening to him is a win-win because
under his deal 100 of Google and YouTube
Revenue was supposed to go directly to
Ethan and the only time the bbtv was
supposed to get paid was when they set
up a sponsorship read with an outside
brand but in a recent video Ethan
explained that he compared his pay stub
to his YouTube analytics and realized
hey my pay doesn't reflect that deal I
noticed it was like significant it's
crushing it so far so far perfect I'm
ready to hide 10 out of 10. at this
point I got my hike
got the sunscreen in my bag the kitten
Lee
off and as far as we could tell they had
skimmed 620
000 at least right that's just from what
we can tell
from specifically the membership money
and client adding they were in
particular pissed him off with line if
you put his ever he's putting respect on
my name is fine
like we're like we're not friends come
on
I mean this is this is legal stuff this
is very important yeah it's important to
be very clear here as Mr Klein stated
membership Revenue these is people
coming
to us to show us their direct support
like that was the whole point of this
program the timing it is specifically
nefarious that they went after that
money
that money which should be held sacred
and if anything if any channel of
Revenue shouldn't be touched by them
it's that
money that fans are giving directly to
us to support our Channel
they shouldn't even be allowed to touch
that frankly
via YouTube's rules
like they you know big language are also
key things to take away from this
remember some background Ethan explained
that he had been working with bbtv since
2017 which notably was before
memberships even existed but even with
that because it's still revenue from
YouTube Ethan argued that it should fall
into the same bucket as ads and he
should still be getting 100 of that but
apparently when speaking to bbtv they
pointed out in other clause in his
contract now these guys
at the [__] audacity
to come to me and say well if you look
at this section your Revenue
and you look here it says 70 of other
net revenues
and they're like well memberships
is other net revenue what I'm apparently
claiming that they were in the right to
keep the six hundred twenty thousand
dollars but now you have Ethan saying
let's let the courts decide because he's
suing bbtv and pointing out that in the
contract they Define Google net revenue
as including Google subscriptions and
even arguing with the definition of
Google subscription should clearly
include memberships they've been saying
you noticed this three days ago and sent
an email to bbtv and claiming in that
email that some of the discrepancies go
all the way back to December of 2020.
then saying it took three days for them
to respond and set up a call Nathan
actually recorded that call and tweeted
today that he plans on publishing it so
he can quote fully expose them as the
thieves bullies and Liars that they are
but he also explained that during that
call bbtv just maintains that they were
in the right to take 30 of the
membership revenue and they would not be
giving it back which is why now Ethan's
membership program is paused while he
works with YouTube to get rid
got that wrong
what do you say the membership isn't
paused
it was paused for a moment he says it's
currently paused oh he needs to issue a
retraction
thank you
I mean as a serious newsman Philly I
would expect well that was the last
publicly known position until this show
today right well he's probably recorded
up on his [__] all right we're being
very nitpicky I'm just saying would not
be giving it back which is why now
Ethan's membership programs paused while
he works with YouTube yeah I'm demanding
a retraction a correction a correction
get rid of his old AdSense account and
make a new one which apparently can be a
lengthy process but that's also not
where this ends because Ethan then went
on Twitter to say he heard that bbtv has
skimmed other creators of their
membership money with a man posting an
update video discussing some of those
new allegations and also pointing to a
Creator by the name of Cabos who tweeted
back in March that bbtv was delaying its
pavement schedule by several weeks my
fear
is that they don't have the money
and that these guys are on the verge of
declaring bankruptcy and second is the
options for terminating his deal with
bbtv and is even willing to pay a ten
thousand dollar penalty fee just to get
out of it but also in order to unlink
his channel from bbtv they actually have
to approve it first with Ethan saying
that his fears are much bigger than him
and his company rather he's concerned
that if bbtv goes bankrupt it could cost
tons of creators lots of money with all
this of course we've seen tons of people
chiming in a lot of craters but
specifically it was interesting to see
creators that actually work with bbtv
also speaking out people like moist
Critical with him saying wait he works
with bbtv
I've never had any issues himself he
works with bbtv that's what Phil just
said oh but it doesn't seem like there's
any basis for them to be taking that 30
should that make it to court I don't see
any world where bbtv can somehow make an
argument that it falls under other
Revenue when it very plainly and clearly
states that it is part of normal YouTube
net revenue
boy thanks bro
I'm waste I love the moist critically
gets it folks he gets it
um
thank you
you know I think part part of why this
isn't
as big or affecting as many people I
don't think people have many people have
this
robust membership uh I agree I feel like
um I feel like we're doing it we gotta
be on the the top edge of uh YouTube
memberships we gotta be top five if not
number one it I mean we got a lot of
very supportive fans and then we have
Legends donating a thousand at a time
yeah thank you so good you know it's
like this is why sometimes I wish I got
more respect from YouTube it's like yeah
they're they're trying so hard to build
out this this gaming and streaming [__]
and here we are streaming [__] four
times a week five times if you include
the membership and it's like
sometimes I feel like they just don't
even listen
but yeah I think that's the problem is
that there's not a lot of big member
ship communities on YouTube yeah
[Music]
well I got a message
everything okay yeah okay
somebody said not to make light of this
but can I sue Dan for winning too hard
no no I'm sorry
they'll get thrown out you'll have to
prove damages yeah
it's not your fault
God I hate them so much
[Music]
[__]
my guy just brought up a terrifying
point
he said
oh God this breaks my heart to even say
it says if they're not unlinking you
till tomorrow they'll they're gonna they
could try to take a cut of this podcast
that's what I asked you at the beginning
well I thought they were making me today
that's what I thought it said I teeth
and damn okay Ethan great day only man
he's payday dude have a good night they
shouldn't [__] touch my Goddamn money
the membership money but it's just one
it could be today they try to [__]
steal our money
that's crazy
that's crazy to me it's not [__]
crazy to take 30 of that I wish you're
being helpful about it today what was I
gonna do Dan I gotta do my show on
Monday no I mean that's fine I just I
specifically asked about that I thought
I thought that they were gonna
disconnect me today
well I guess we'll find out I mean all
of it gets reconciled at the end of the
month so
so it might be fine
right that's true because it's a monthly
valuation yeah I think you're right if
it goes into the monthly pool a month
right
yeah they always like Bill it monthly if
it goes into the monthly pool and they
disconnect us on the 10th how did they
how did they decide
you know what they shouldn't be touching
a goddamn Penny yeah I mean that's the
reality of the situation but goddamn
dude dude God damn them dude
do you know
um because all of this talk has been
exclusively about the member's
subscription there is a other um
you know direct Revenue like the super
chats were they taking 30 of those too
I think those
I don't know
it's worth investigating because if
they're taking that super fast didn't
exist in 2017. either I don't know yeah
hold on let me ask what the [__] I never
thought about that yeah I mean compared
to the membership money that's you know
probably I'm asking my my accountant
right now
[Music]
uh
not gonna lie I don't want the podcast
to end but like all good things what are
you telling us to wrap it up
but then they're going to say a b good
luck Ethan looking damn fine and the
rest of the team y'all kings and queens
I gotta say
um
a lot of people find Angry vengeful uh
aggressive business Ethan uh very
attractive I was a lot of a lot of
simping in the chat for you today yeah
well I'm broken
when he's yelling at people yeah well
I'm 620 000 Broker Than I was so that's
not sexy
you're always rich with that hairline
dude no thank you love
you're bound to fall in follicles that's
for sure thank you guys thank you
you know I wonder should we post the
Zach one tomorrow
or should we wait till the disconnect
happens I would wait for that
I mean we're not with the Zack video or
not expecting you know we were thinking
too for future member content that would
be awesome
I think this was Love's idea right we
were going to react
right as a group to the Zack highlights
to the lore videos because they're
there's so much to say about them I mean
they're just you know that would be
awesome members content
you I feel so bad dude I'm so sorry you
guys if they take [__]
if they try to take 30 from today I just
honestly feel horrible
that is just that is
ah
oh God
it's kind of ironic I mean it's yeah
what can you do but laugh
this is kind of ironic they're like
they're probably sitting at home like
yeah memberships oh baby
yes that's like when Dr Dre made a this
about Easy E and he but he was still in
her contract so he said Trey Day only
met he's he's payday that's pretty much
what this is
I swear I swear to God
our our other uh company that get that
actually gets Us ads that we love love
them um our rep from there has been he
he's been watching Ethan yeah he's
saying that he's just been dying this
whole time and I see now they actually
said they're waiting to release you
until tomorrow knowing they're knowing
you're going to do this video today
yo I was wondering why they picked
Tuesday
you think they're that I don't know if
they're that serious but well why would
they pick two he said her with a
laughing emoji so I'm pretty sure he was
joking but uh why would they pick
Tuesday I ever thought that I was like
that's random it is kind of random I
gotta say the the roost is the only
company I've ever worked with where I
don't feel like I'm being scammed yeah
they Rock they've been great and not
only that man like the times that
they've
let's say I don't want to say let's say
there was times where
like companies maybe one didn't pay them
for the spots because they pay them and
they pay us they they've like gone into
their own pocket to make it good for us
right and like that is real [__] that's
like so so they're living they're living
uh the bbtv CEO's philosophy ethical
living it practice we love you Roost we
love you take my money please
well he has risen guys he's risen he's
up he's walking
having a good time
[__] I gotta find out about super the
Super Chat
is there
Super Chat God damn it I'll have that
answer
[__] would they really do that
I mean they would
I feel like when I've seen before that
Super Chat money gets clumped with
membership money in the back end so I
would not be surprised I don't know that
I don't know 100 but that's what made me
ask is I remember seeing that kind of
well you're right if they can take it
they will
if it didn't exist when we signed the
contract they'll definitely have taken
it yeah so there's that
it's where Sam's Jeep fund went bbtv
stole Sam's Jeep
[Laughter]
so she had to get a Subaru
this sucks um as fun as I seem to have
it I'm actually quite dreading having to
go deal with this but whatever
not as much as sharz out is probably
more like shark zad
go dude
let's [__] go
all right
thank you Zach for backing me up when no
one else would except love all right
let's call it a day uh thank you guys
yeah Emily Baker could be fun to talk to
about this
I mean it would be fun to have a lawyer
just be like
obviously this is insane
and she just comes in for a minute and
they're like all right Emily Baker well
thank you always uh she always comments
on big Leo stuff that's going on on
YouTube I I have to imagine she's
planning on uh diving into this even
yeah and Emily I'll send you the whole
contract I'll post the whole contract on
Twitter I don't give a [__] about him
maybe after the show uh DMR I will spend
the whole contract on Twitter I don't
care about anything do you guys
understand how [__] crazy I am
bring back the goblin music Here's bbtv
posting
happy Halloween everyone here are some
of our favorite costumes that our bbtv
fam wore I didn't even know you posted
this weirdness this is a disc
you guys are Dumb and Dumber they're
saying they're like we're we were
robbing these two look at these idiots
we're robbing them blind right right
Dumb and Dumber over here
you know [__] you
and they try to be like yeah we're just
we're fam you guys I was like I don't
even know who you are I don't talk to
you ever I never saw this I don't care
about you I don't think about you you do
nothing for me hey the bbtv fan we're in
the family
[Music]
oh why
what yeah so there we go we've got a new
a new uh villain Arc
right
Ryan's on ice
wait what do you got for me love
oh you want another voice to clip you
want me to do a critical reaction
yeah
I don't know how I'm gonna react to that
it was only like 10 seconds long
this is important this is how we grow
the channel we're actually like over the
like over the top like hell yeah Charlie
you've always been my boy you've always
done right back yeah right
it's an interesting clip come on a man
yeah super interesting
you can remove the Ethan's or maybe keep
it up oh yeah
that is concerning I did see that
what's that
uh H yo he saw it yo I wonder what he
thinks about it yo Charlie let's get
let's get this reaction crazy what does
he think about it
oh man bbtv
uh stole 620
000 from him that's my opinion for the
record and I clearly in all my videos in
the title put in my opinion
good luck swimming for defamation
[__]
dummies
over the course of multiple years
so apparently
in the contract bbtv says that they will
give all of like normal net revenue yeah
for a channel to that channel exactly
yep that's exactly what it says yeah you
know you know
um
but would keep like other Revenue
and I under their vague terms other
Revenue meant his channel memberships
so they would took what was it 30
percent of all the channel memberships
or something over the course of like
five years or whatever they've been
there
which amounted to 620 000 that
doesn't really uh have justification for
it because thank you Charlie he said I'm
so you know what I've always been a fan
of Charlie yup I love Charlie and I'm
glad to see him supporting creators
which is what's important we got to
stick together and he knows that and
that's why I've always loved him yep
if you look at the Analytics
for like YouTube net revenue the channel
memberships are included in that they
don't go to like other Revenue category
right so it really doesn't seem like
bbtv had the right to take 30 of that
good point that's a great Point that's a
fantastic same bucket that's good
Charlie's always on Charlie never misses
in the game
he might be moist but his takes are dry
or I mean critical they're well I'm
trying to contrast the he's moist but
his takes are fire p word okay there oh
there you go there it is there it is
nice yes very nice
so now this is going to end up going to
court if they don't pay him back and it
seems like they're very against paying
him back
don't you guys work with bbtv hey it
turns out I'm an investor in bbtv
ha
I might be one of their biggest
benefactors yeah
yep
well I even use an MCN
it was just for the sake of convenience
at the time see that that's what I'm
saying he's he Charlie who has a massive
Channel
uh is in the same [__] thing that I
am with the same network it's like it
you know it's crazy that these it makes
sense years ago there was a purpose to
it once it's just they've kind of become
outmoded but you're you know but here's
the thing Charlie should be afraid
because despite the fact that they never
screwed him
he probably doesn't have membership on
he may not have membership on but does
he have super chats I think he streams
on Twitch oh he always streams on
Twitter he doesn't stream on YouTube
okay fair enough yeah yeah so
so
they are still collecting your money
before they pay you out that means they
have two months to
hold on to your money
so long it's just been so long
they are kind of like no one really uses
them anymore
most of them don't really exist but it's
just been so long so I've been there for
a very long time exactly
it's weird but like that's just but I've
never had a problem with them they've
always been like really responsive and
nice but uh this is very concerning I'm
sure Ethan would have said the same
thing about him until three days ago
he's actually right I would have yeah
the few times that we've needed them for
something
um you know they were they were helpful
and like we said they every once in a
while would throw an ad our way and it
just because they were supposedly giving
you 100 it was just like why not it
wasn't really like no we were getting 75
of the sponsors oh I meant for the other
stuff for like the the AdSense and
everything when they would bring us a a
sponsor right
but he's right you know the guy I worked
with was nice and responsive that's why
I was like you're cool [__] everyone
else
but uh yeah I for sure would have
noticed that 620k over the last five or
whatever years has been uh not reported
the contract clearly shows membership
Revenue isn't part of the 30 cut yeah
that's why I said it doesn't seem like
there's any basis for them to be taking
that thirty percent do you read the
subscriptions definition
so
should that make it to court I don't see
any world where bbtv can somehow make an
argument that it falls under other
Revenue when it very plainly and clearly
states that it is part of normal YouTube
net revenue
so with their own terms it seems like
it's an easy slam done for Ethan to win
thank you Charlie
King you're slim very good very good
take
a perfect take
yeah by the way you seeing his physique
strong oh unbelievable beautiful hair
unbelievable
I might actually even get a tick tock
clip out of that that's great it's a
very good absolutely I'm not done yet or
am I oh
Maybe
I like this part but yeah I see a lot of
people don't like Ethan and that's
totally fine
ah
what did I do like what the [__] did I
do
you gotta denounce me dude we didn't his
chat was probably full of a bunch of
people being like ill a lot of people
don't like Ethan and that's totally fine
you don't have to you should cut that
yeah sound bite that sir you got it like
everyone or anything but you can
recognize that a situation extends far
beyond just one person there I saw a lot
of people on Twitter point out the same
thing that bbtv has been taking all
their Channel membership revenue or at
30 of their base Charlie but I do love I
do love that aside yeah I understand
everybody here hates Ethan but you got
to look past that he didn't do anything
wrong he's gracious I know it's just
funny to see
it's so like pervasive
the Ethan hate
as everybody knows Ethan is the worst
person on YouTube we all agree on that
but what happened to him guys is super
messed up
it's like a dog [__] on his own
balls and then forgetting to
wipe it on the carpet and then it gets
all over the place and somebody tracks
it into the other room and right dildo
falls on the ground and it rolls around
in the [__] and now yeah
that's [__] good
ah we kid
we kid the ones we love
uh Dextero oh so he I guess he's
planning on moving to multi-streaming to
YouTube so he better get his ducks in a
row
yeah look out for that
yeah
um there was one other thing I just
which I can't get enough of this
it just makes me so I just crack up
every time when you just go to like
their goddamn page
YouTube's goddamn page
active members all members with active
subscriptions
what
that's it I mean it says it everywhere
yeah does it in every possible situation
where membership is described as a
subscription
you know
not funny
that [__] hilarious
it's funny I guess they can still pay me
back and we can just like say Hey you
know it's never too late to admit you're
wrong and I've learned that by so
there's been times in my life and in my
career where I've gotten defensive and
it took me time to to come around to the
idea that I was wrong and that's where
personal growth begins right when you
can swallow your pride and confront the
uh
the uncomfortable truth
which is that you are wrong and
everybody knows it that's the worst part
right like it's not too late they could
they could pay me back and then I would
say you know what
actually I think they're deathly afraid
of that because that means they'll have
to pay everybody back God knows how much
money they've owed people for this
dude they're so [__]
they're so [__] because if they pay me
back they have to pay everyone back
uh I'm never getting my money back God
damn it
I'm never getting it back
well we'll see
all right dummies well sleep well
tonight bbtv scumbags
hope you guys are having as much fun as
I am with this one
[Music]
don't spend that 160 don't spend that
620 all in one spot
[Music]
600 DPI
[Laughter]
hey uh hey uh charzad you better cut
yourself a quick executive bonus now
before the bankruptcy courts get a hold
of it
mm-hmm
here's bbtv Instagram post I never seen
they posted this ever asked me if they
could post this nobody cares dude why is
this one's so weird it has 57 000 I
think they're fake
but then if you go to the other ones it
only has like three do you think we
shared it it's possible maybe we shared
it I think because they have other ones
with exactly 57 000 likes as well too
like this one has like nothing
this one doesn't even there's like
nothing
and just wants a picture of a sandwich
or it's a video
here's a picture of
why are you posting this [__] it's none
of your [__] business
like that's weird you guys
[__] your [__] [__] it's like part
of our family it's like no you're not
at all
you know not at all it's the ghost of BB
TV there we were there we watched the
delivery it was magical we're part of
the family
we get 30 of the placenta
it has incredible healing properties
yeah we eat it we consume it
all right let's go before you get
canceled I got the button sorry uh but
anyway here's the post where I want to
talk about and this will be the last one
how dare you
I didn't I don't know who you are I
don't know you appreciation post for one
of our favorite Crews on our favorite
podcast
if you haven't listened before you are
missing out on some of the best chaos of
your life oh yeah are you enjoying that
chaos now
oh [__] I forgot this is when Eli didn't
have eyebrows or she dyed it I got I
gotta admit that was a pretty wild look
but it's it was Brave of her and I
appreciate that she's willing to
to do that this is a great photo I love
this photo of us
this is so I think the only one where I
wasn't in it it's kind of [__] rude
I'm not gonna lie yo [__] BB TV oh [__]
BB idiots [__] yeah dumbass it is
dumbass idiot company idiot morons
best chaos of your life man this sucks I
hate them so much
I gotta call it attorney I got two
attorney references I gotta call them
and see if I like them which is annoying
I like usually I just want to work with
an attorney I know because whenever you
pick a new one it's like you never know
what you're gonna get
even if it's like a huge reputable super
expensive firm dumb people work there
too and they suck and they just charge
you more
so I gotta you never know what you're
going to get thank you gum
just like that
so now I gotta call these guys and I got
to explain the situation to all of them
again
I gotta send them all the documents and
[__]
life was like a box of chocolates can
you guys just pay me back
just pay me back
[Music]
that sounds like a good plan and
everybody else yeah everybody wins pay
everyone else back too
how about just CL just retire
just retire
just close the business and give
everyone their money back and just walk
away peacefully so you can retire better
right
all right guys thank you for watching
it's been a hell of a ride huh
thank you to bbtv for a
[Applause]
well I look forward to receiving more
legal letters and I think it's fantastic
and exciting
wait people are sending me all kinds of
crazy bbtv [__] now wait someone sent me
a archived stop sending it to him people
so wait this is this is the one from
before they updated it
but what does this one say I I are you
talking about this they sent me this and
they said it's archives yeah I I didn't
really tell a difference I don't think
there's really much there to be honest
they say subscribers oh no that's
unrelated it pretty much is the same but
yeah it is interested that I said
updated today
mm-hmm
I see
[Music]
a lot of these people uh like her oh
yeah 57 000 exactly the [__] is going on
over there
exactly 57 000. just how many fans I
have
well damn we have very precisely 57
000 fans
weirdos
freaks losers
idiots on messes
seriously stupid idiot dumbasses
[__]
or maybe I put it another way you're a
bunch of [__]
they are a bunch of [__] thanks Rudy
I have so many images from different
devices different subscribers it's all
subscription
[Music]
I can write a novel about how it's a
subscription yeah okay I got back from
my finance she said the only thing they
are taking a percentage of is
okay so it seems like they are not
taking from the
[Applause]
that's what she said she said they're
only taking from
from uh sponsorships
seems to hurt their case even more
because they're not treating it all
equally right
right that's even more other than that's
that's way more other than Channel
membership that's way more other bro huh
we just gave him an idea they just found
a new Revenue stream right
funny
well that's real interesting baby TV
ah they must be so [__] like
I don't know I don't care I'm gonna go
home and relax charzad I'm gonna spend
some time with my kids I'm probably
gonna order some Mexican food have a
really nice night with my family and
then you know what when everyone's
asleep I'm gonna chill and I'm gonna
play the bindings of Isaac and I'm gonna
sit at home Carefree nice maybe watch
some reality TV with my lovely wife and
I'm not gonna think about you at all
oh yeah I'm not gonna think about any of
you at all but I'll tell you this this
is the face that is gonna haunt your
dreams
[Music]
do something about it hold me
accountable
you can you can you can fade out
I think everyone left for the day
everyone's leaving Zach just left the
music on
this
I am your sleep paralysis demon now
Charizard
you can't wake up
you're fighting you're trying to sit up
you're paralyzed this is the face
floating over you
[Music]
and I'll just say this you [__] up
you [__] up
[Music]